[Laughter]
hey
guys it's friday night yep and here we
are once again
with our cocktails yep and our
bullshittery yeah
[Laughter]
and look at tom's new omega man shirt
yup
mega man shirt that did come out nice
didn't it but
if i do say so myself yeah
yeah
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
yeah and um honestly just yesterday
i actually ordered
i kind of i finally broke down and
ordered a printer
uh so i would actually be able to print
out the transparencies to make the
screens from here
instead of having to drive all the way
to the [ __ ] print shop yep
because you know and we can ship out
from here now yeah i also ordered a
postage scale and uh you know in a
postal
uh what do you call it so you can print
out from your
from your house and they'll come and
pick your [ __ ] up
so uh i gotta mail some shirts out to uh
my boy over there texas
and then
we'll probably eventually do a mass mail
out here
uh maybe next month we'll see we'll see
how the money is we've been behind on
them on the mass shirt mail outs to our
uh yeah i mean especially since we've
moved
well because it's killed us well because
one it you know sucked up all our money
and two
um the print shop that we always use for
our stuff is like way far away now and
the post office that's close to us
doesn't have um you know post offices
have like the shelf serve yeah so where
you can just go in and weigh the [ __ ]
and use the machines like whenever like
in the middle of the night or whatever
if you want to and the post office bias
doesn't have that so it's kind of a pain
in the ass right to have to go and like
wait in line to like you have to go when
it's open you can't go like on sunday or
whatever so so it's a lot better that we
got this new song so i was like you know
what i'm just gonna break down and run
this [ __ ] like a business we'll just do
it from the house and run the [ __ ] yeah
so i got a good deal actually i waited
till amazon prime day
and they had a good deal on a
hewlett-packard printer scanner copier
and it came with six months free ink
refills yeah which is good because the
ink cartridges are like 40 to 60 dollars
but i got three of the new four four new
designs ready
uh i'll show them later on in the show
when we got more people in the
in here they're just starting to show up
now but it's a
omega man that you see here
i got corralco
studios
and then um i got canon studios done
and i'm just waiting on ocp
telecommunications from robocop got that
i'll probably have that in a couple days
yeah he was working on him last night
yeah not we have a lot of shirts in
stock we have a lot of sizes in stock
so we can do a mail out once well i mean
i have to check
what all i have is right we got to look
because i have a bunch in the closet but
i don't remember like what all sizes we
have so i feel kind of female stuff yeah
i feel because i feel kind of bad
because it's like you know people that
are you know patrons and people that pay
for stuff it's like we always try to do
like mail outs at least like a couple
times a year but yeah because we got
behind yeah and like i said it was kind
of like [ __ ] up and like i said just
because the print shop was so far away
now and it was a painted mask and
transparencies and then it was like a
pain in the ass to bail stuff out
because the
post office wasn't you know all thing
but and the economy is bad for everybody
so
super chats are kind of drying up i had
to [ __ ] do both of those outside
air conditioner units and that was
[ __ ] 700 bucks right there just to
get those ready for the summer because i
sure as hell not can't live in this
place without air conditioning this is
yeah now this big two-story house and
kill you in here that's what i'm saying
it's like if yeah if this house didn't
have air conditioning i'd be like bye
i'm moving to like [ __ ] elaborate i'd
be better off just living in my backyard
underneath the [ __ ] tarp i'm just
gonna be i'll be hitchhiking up to
[ __ ] maine or some [ __ ]
somewhere cold
but yeah so i'm kind of happy we got the
new printer i was able to
i was actually able to print out the
tickets for the uh we're going to see
the temple of mercy tomorrow night yeah
at will's pub who is obviously a
sister's university cover band
we'll see if they're good i mean
i'm sure how how they they got to be
good right
no
that could be bad but we'll see
that's the spirit yeah
i bet they're not though yeah i bet
they're not
it'll be fun it'll be fun
i like will's pub anyway
so yeah that's tomorrow night so i'm
excited about that
and then
today like i said we had a big day i had
to go buy some ink i had to go
you had to go to the dmv yeah get my new
driver's license you had a new driver's
license i had to get my picture taken
i looked like [ __ ] in a picture they
were like you want to try it again and i
was like nah [ __ ] it
it's gonna look [ __ ] up
you should have been like yeah
my [ __ ] face is just like a round
moon [ __ ] right now it's like a
[ __ ] pie face
i look like joe rogan now you know
i'm [ __ ] holding a lot of water whose
fault is that i'm on a cycle i'm on a
side
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] kind of swollen so
don't complain carrying a lot of water
[ __ ] taking my blood pressure
medicine trying to [ __ ]
piss it all out it's just [ __ ] crazy
it's the crazy [ __ ] we do man
yeah what's your problem
trying to gain weight and then
and then you go to dmv and they have to
take a picture of you and you're like my
head looks like a bowling ball
used to have cheekbones and [ __ ] now i
just look like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] pie
look like a [ __ ] apple pie
cut some slits in it
ugly [ __ ] i will i'll give you a
hundred dollars if you dress up like an
apple pie for halloween
just with like an apple fire [ __ ]
apple put your little face oh
his [ __ ] apple pie face he looks like
a [ __ ] apple pie too
oh look there we go
thank you
this is still the coolest podcast thank
you so much
we just sit here talking about how ugly
that [ __ ] is famous though man
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] huge
wish i had that show
i mean you know yeah and he just gets on
there and listens and asks questions and
yeah you know yeah
he's got a good show though he's funny
what makes what makes rogan's show
good is that he doesn't um he doesn't
talk over the guest he just asks
questions and lets them talk it's a real
long form they didn't have that back in
the day closest thing to that when we
were coming up would be larry king live
and you had that old [ __ ] mummy up
there
[ __ ] little suspenders with his
suspenders
and he's like 60 married to like a
[ __ ] 17 year old
he does some [ __ ]
that i don't think she did i think she
was like 19. i was gonna say yes she was
like let's not go with miners here he
was like [ __ ]
68 and she's like 19. she's probably
like please die soon please die saying
please oh yeah i'm sure
i'm sure she had was having kids i mean
if i was her that's what i did she was
having kids with him and everything i
think she [ __ ] inherited the damn
empire i mean he was you know
imagine that
it's not he wasn't robbing the cradle
she was robbing the grave well yeah
pretty much yeah i mean the thing about
it though it's like
in a way kind of like good on them
because i wouldn't i mean yeah they're
probably like yeah i probably only have
to put up with this [ __ ] dude
for a few years and then he'll croak and
then i can have all his [ __ ]
yeah but and they know those dudes know
yeah i know that you know but i'm just
saying if you can i don't see i don't
know if i could do that man i don't know
if i could i mean and no i know i could
have been a viable [ __ ] mating
strategy for females and now thousands
of years
like i said i admire chicks that can do
that because i don't think i could do it
it's like i could probably i could maybe
you know what i don't even think i could
put up with like a dude that old or like
crotchety in like for [ __ ] 10 minutes
much less athletic gears in here i don't
know what he was really like
you never know maybe he was super cool i
don't know i don't i don't know though
remember remember [ __ ]
big fine chunky
and a nicole smith
yeah remember her with her 96 year old
[ __ ] billionaire boyfriend yeah
everybody she got married to him
and then they i totally love him yeah
yeah he's in the wheelchair and [ __ ] i
totally love his money he's giving him
[ __ ] titty dances and [ __ ] [ __ ]
throwing him on his face they got this
[ __ ] on video i'm not making it up it's
hilarious no i know and he he left
everything to her and his [ __ ] family
was [ __ ] livid of course and uh and
then he died
and they fought that [ __ ] tooth and nail
i don't think she got
i thought i think she got a settlement
but i don't know i don't remember how
that was resolved i don't think she got
the umbrella and then she died soon
after yeah
because you just can't give anybody
money you know and they gave hannah
nicole [ __ ] money
and she just [ __ ] bought pills with
it
killed herself
just some people are just gonna get high
you know
in a way that like makes me so mad i'm
like yeah all those people like with all
that money they're just like pissing it
away
like i wish i could give me that because
i'm not going to buy drugs but then i
promise
having real money is a skill
because uh that [ __ ] destroys the
average person just kills them well i
mean i can understand that to a degree
because if you were raised with no money
and you know you never really learned to
like manage and it's it puts you in like
an entirely different world
and
especially if you grew up with nothing
um and you're kind of like you know you
had to pinch every penny and now
suddenly it seems like the money's
endless so i kind of feel like a lot of
them like you see this with uh you know
people that are like lower middle class
or whatever and then they win the
lottery yeah and then like it only takes
like a few years and they blown all of
it it's either gone or they're dead
because i think i mean an amount of
money that large like i said if i won 10
million dollars to me that might as well
be infinite money but it's not infinite
money no so i spin that [ __ ] up that's
what i mean if you don't don't watch it
you could easily spend that in a few
years like if you're just like just well
yeah i don't care give me a boat give me
a car give me this and that give me a
million it'll be gone i'll spend that in
a week that's what i mean yeah a house
and a couple of cars and that'd be and
then it'd be gone and then it'd be gone
so i kind of feel like i get that
because like to me like i said even
something like a billion dollars or 10
million dollars to me might as well be
infinite money but
in a way too
i think it's better because i kind of
grew up without any money so i learned
to live without a bunch of [ __ ] and i
don't really care about a bunch of [ __ ]
i don't want a boat i don't want a plane
i don't want gold-plated anything i
don't want you know what i mean a lot of
stuff i don't want it my family
if you guys don't know maybe the story
of my fam my family kind of came and
went you know what i mean it went up and
down through the socioeconomic ladder
okay
[ __ ] it depending on what we were doing
for a living when [ __ ] my family was
in brazil with that dental manufacturing
facility i'm going to make [ __ ]
several million a year
yeah you you actually lived a high life
for several years but that
only went on for about 25 years but you
all had a maid and everything right yeah
yeah you all hadn't made it you had
three of them yeah three mates
and then uh i don't know what that would
be like yeah
our house was an entire floor of a
[ __ ] brazilian apartment building in
sao paulo yes
was the [ __ ] company that my stepdad
owned
[ __ ] pissed me off that he lost that
[ __ ] because i'd have got my hands on
that crap and i'd have been better at it
than he was he was my stepdad was a dick
he's dead i can say it now i thought
that was a dick he was a dick i knew
yeah [ __ ] dick imagine max vaughn
side out but he's a dick he's like that
don't besmirch the name of max von sydow
maxwell's is awesome
i don't even want that association yeah
he made a lot of enemies and they
eventually came from him and took his
empire
and uh
brazil's basically run by cartels
cartel families it's not drugs it's just
every business is owned by some kind of
a [ __ ] oligarch cartel [ __ ] type
person and they own all the courts they
can get laws passed to [ __ ] you over
everything's corrupt corrupt and crooked
amer you americans and and especially
you europeans your [ __ ] is set on novice
all right brazil is set on expert
all right nothing makes sense you have
to be
you have to think so far outside the box
you have to think like a criminal you'll
never survive because everything you do
is illegal
including how you handle your money
you're exchanging money on black market
yeah so you have to know because so you
have to know parallel exchange rates
you got to do in several different kind
of currencies
because the government is the government
is a [ __ ] machine to just steal
the brazilian government
people talking [ __ ] about bolsonaro
because
oh yeah bolsonaro he's addicted no he's
not they're calling him they're calling
him that because he's trying to [ __ ]
uproot a [ __ ] deeply entrenched
[ __ ] crime cartel that controls
brazil
the function of the brazilian government
is to tell you no
anything you want to do they tell you no
then you have to pay for some kind of
license to get permission to do it
that's the purpose of the brazilian good
nothing to do with helping people none
of that's grift
and i'm talking about it's so bad you
can't buy a box of tools or a set of
tools because that's industrial
[ __ ] capability like the idea of
going down to the store and buying a set
of tools to fix your car that doesn't
exist in brazil
that doesn't that doesn't happen that's
under the control of some kind of
dealerships and things that have special
licenses to have those
[ __ ] tools it's it's a joke the whole
thing's a joke so
our problems are nothing compared to
[ __ ] what brazil's problems are
and i grew up in that
towards the end of the dictatorship era
of brazil and some people are scared of
dictatorship although dictation
dictatorship was an improvement for
brazil
because before then it was just [ __ ]
chaos and then it eventually improved
into a [ __ ] dictatorship because the
dictatorship can function
what it was before that was just like
find my republic it was there was no
country
basically and the dictatorship doesn't
tell citizens what to do it tells what
elected officials what to do
because
in that system you elect an official all
he does is steal he wants free money
he's not going to do his job
so the dictator [ __ ] forces elected
officials to do their job under [ __ ]
penalty of punishment
because they won't under any other you
know they won't if if they don't have a
dictator there
they'd be told what to do
and you have to it has to be done under
a pain pleasure principle if you obey
you're rewarded if you disobey you're
punished
because you can't leave them to their
own [ __ ] devices they'll just
they'll do nothing
or steal
because the
they're too they're too immoral
so
things happen for a reason
and uh i still love brazil it's a
[ __ ] trip
and
unless you've grown up there you'll
never understand it any brazilians
every brazilian i grew up with
the good ones they're all here
especially the girls
they're all here
it's because their families evacuated
them to safety they sent them here to
florida
we were talking about money before our
camp guy said uh my mother spent almost
every cent she had in nursing homes over
one or two million bucks and she was
broke when she died at age 90. best
nursing homes over 10k a month yeah man
i've had years where i didn't make 10k
yep i mean the thing about it
i don't know like
when we were talking about anna nicole
smith and her
super old husband yeah
um
i guess well was the argument to be made
that
he wasn't in his right mind when he
willed all his money to her says that
that was
because i don't know that much about
like i know it happened but i don't
really know all the details yeah okay
the family argued that he was too old to
know what he was doing
and that and that that's what i figured
she came in
and [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
basically tricked him into into this
marriage and everything
but dude people that knew that old man
said oh no he knew exactly what he was
doing he hated his family
all right well see that's what i mean
it's just as long as they have all their
mental faculties then i think their will
should be valid i mean you know he said
he hated his family his family just
basically used him up for money and he
liked anna cause she had because she was
fun and had big old titties
all right he's like that's really good
that's all he meant she was fun he had
big old titties and she was funny and
she was dumb and anna was dumb dumb as
dumb as [ __ ] okay but she was
entertaining
being dumb has nothing to do with being
likable [ __ ] i've known a lot of dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ] they're just
likable i'd do [ __ ] yeah
other than over a smart person uh highly
intelligent people that i knew that
[ __ ] ended up getting [ __ ] big
degrees and [ __ ] some of them i grew up
with they're not likable
you know i wouldn't trust them either a
lot of them
but they need some dumb dude you know
what i mean who works at the auto store
[ __ ] you know what i mean or [ __ ]
works at the auto shop you know he'll do
anything for you
totally loyal like a doubt like a dog
you know but he means it
you know and give you the shirt off his
back he's got nothing
so just you know but just dumb but
that doesn't mean he's a bad person or
unlikable
you know a lot of times
that's that's the thing about a lot of
women they they go to these universities
they think it's going to give them
better meat selection when they get out
no
now guys guys will take a dumb girl
who's pretty and who's fun and likable
over
kind of a girl who's making a lot of
money but she's just kind of mediocre i
don't think that they'll take that i
don't think that that's why women go to
universities actually
[Laughter]
you read into to get better well that's
what it sounded like you were
implementing i know a lot of girls that
went to the ivy league and they thought
that they would make them real popular
with guys and it didn't
guys don't care about that
yeah i know they don't well most people
know that yeah
so i'm just saying that if they do that
they're just doing it for their own
identification they're not doing it for
some a lot of those girls
[ __ ] high power the dumb ass man
[Laughter]
you're chasing dick okay [ __ ] a lot
of those girls would um
end up being in the same situation as a
lot of those real high earning
chinese and japanese girls that they
have to import a boyfriend
because um
a japanese guy won't go out with a woman
that makes more than him because they're
going to feel cupped out
you know like they feel they're not a
man oh yeah i don't understand not a man
yeah like oh yeah she makes more money
what does she need me for you know it's
that kind of deal she's like you're
right we don't
you know they want they want to get
married though yeah
don't don't project into those women no
i'm just saying no i was making a joke i
was just kind of saying they're trying
to get married but the guys won't
marry them yeah well they need to find
some
[ __ ] that are more secure yeah
and
in japan they were importing them
they're importing them from the west
putting out [ __ ]
they had dating agencies and everything
to find them guys that looked like
models that didn't have a pot to piss in
but were entertaining which dudes were
doing that
getting [ __ ] ukrainian and russian
girlfriends that didn't have a pot to
piss him but she looked great you know
what i mean you can afford to keep them
so they have a relationship with that
well that's what those japanese girls
were doing
yeah i don't know why billionaires i
don't know why everybody gets so like
head up when it's a woman doing it it's
like i don't like dudes dude have been
doing that for like [ __ ] centuries
yeah i don't i don't i i totally
understand if a chick can afford if
that's what she wants to do it's like i
wouldn't bother like wasting my money
but you know if you want to then hey
more power to you there's a a real
good-looking chinese
um
bodybuilder girl who's on instagram and
she does cosplay and little bodybuilding
stuff she dresses up like anime
characters
she's
a single unwed mother
and
which makes her totally unmarriageable
in in china chinese dude wouldn't touch
it she's damaged good damage
[Laughter]
so
she just becomes a [ __ ] total
knockout in the gym
does all and becomes this [ __ ] big
online sensation
and um becomes a [ __ ] superstar
so anybody can overcome anything
you know but here's the thing
those dudes wouldn't marry her but she
don't think she'd marry any of them
dudes
well yeah that's what i mean it's
probably like when you look at the dudes
that are out there who are available to
her get married
these are these little hundred and ten
hundred twenty pound skinny chinese guys
they'd look at her with all those
muscles and [ __ ] and they'd go [ __ ] oh
no oh no she could kick my ass oh yeah
but i did see a photograph of her with
just a chinese mass monster like huge
chinese bodybuilder and i think that was
probably i think that's probably more
what she's into
you know and
they probably you know they probably go
for that
well people are always more i mean
naturally like attract to like people
that are into the same [ __ ] as them so
it's like you know if you have the same
hobbies yeah then you know that's gonna
be uh sebastian says schizoid was a
terrible movie i think uh craig was
wasan was in a better one called body
double honestly we should probably do
body double at some point sounds
familiar yeah it's brian de palma yeah
um and it's actually yeah it's really
good and i'm amazed that we haven't done
it yet but yeah we'll get around to it i
promise
uh but yeah maybe we should do it this
week i'll see if it's available anywhere
um
i got like way behind on the comments
oscar says long day now to listen to a
couple of my favorite people yeah all
right danny says an omega man crew neck
shirt would be cool to buy just saying i
would do any special orders
okay a crew neck does that mean
turtleneck
no what does that mean crewneck is like
a
like that no that's a boat neck
is crew deck like square
i thought it was square i don't know i
can't remember but if we we neck is kind
of a wider
we have a pretty good um
source that sells uh
the shirts yeah jeffy shirts the price
yeah jiffy shirts the prices uh vary
quite a bit
uh muscle t is like almost was it 12
bucks each
depends on the size and depends on like
i said it depends on what it's made of
which is
this one i think was 12 bucks
and um wasn't it 12 i think it looked no
six what
it was like six i don't remember and
then the regular ones were like only
three dollars depending on the size
though well i mean it was like
three times or the price so it might
have been more than honestly it's just
kind of like jiffy shirts they're
awesome because one they have like a
massive selection two their shipping is
like super quick if i order something
one day um like 99 of the time it shows
up the next day unless they have a
problem getting something
but
the thing about it is that they have so
much selection that sometimes it's
really like overwhelming because it's
like look i just want a black t-shirt
and then they're like look we have 50
bajillion different black t-shirts this
one's cotton this one's kind of a true
neck is the traditional t-shirt you buy
the rolling stones yeah i got those okay
so that's just regular yeah it's a
regular t-shirt i got those got them in
stock yeah for some reason i was
thinking that was yeah
like something i i mean i tend to like
the ones that are like softer
yeah um and you know i'm a girl so i
like the fitted ones i don't really like
like the boy sizes or the unisex ones
which are not unisex they're man shirts
um i like the women's cuts because
they're fitted
but and i also kind of like the softer
ones but i know that people don't
usually and honestly we usually try to
get
cotton ones because the ink takes better
because they have some that are cotton
polyester blend
and sometimes those are comfy but the
ink will take but not as well and i
don't think it lasts as long
100 cotton is usually like the way to go
on that
at least is in my experience i'm going
to show you guys that chinese girl that
i said it does the bodybuilding and the
uh
and the cosplay stuff
i think she's fantastic and i think
that's a better way of doing
bodybuilding [ __ ] all that judges in the
shows you know what i mean
dress up as some [ __ ] make some videos
but her name is uh
yuan herrong
that's the name
i'm trying to get it to focus on there
you can see it right there
but she she posts some really cool [ __ ]
yeah craig watson was was in the third
elm street movie yes he was and he was
in ghost story which i think we did a
review of ghost story like a while back
it was actually i i actually kind of
like that movie but
man that did they take a lot out of the
book i understand why they did because
the book is like [ __ ] hella hella
along and they had to take out a bunch
of plot threads but i think they did a
good adaptation
slash your friend said one of these days
you should watch and review the film
moonwalker
maybe we should
that was ada wong from uh oh you messed
up uh the oh dude the lighting
yeah
look at it it's all [ __ ] up there we
go no it's not
uh why do you do this
okay there we go it'll take a second
yeah that's ada wong from uh resident
evil should dress up as anything should
dress up as
ancient egyptian
queens and
anime characters
okay i said i'm basically just sitting
around in my tiny whities all day trying
to stay cool right now some days i have
to change two or three times
holy [ __ ]
do you not have air conditioning
patriots revenge is howdy from your
older younger brother whatever that
means
[Laughter]
your older younger brother
like that
oh we should tell the reason that i
called this show the all you can eat
edition
was because
today like i said we had to go
to the mount dora air right area
and run some errands like i said i had
to go to office depot and then he had to
go to the dmv and he's like hey i think
we're only a couple miles from
the trough
the oyster trough
so we popped in there for
lunch
and they had today a special
all you can eat
fried mahi mahi yeah [ __ ] was good it's
like um tom got that yeah i got that 12
i was like i can't eat all that much so
that all you can eat is like wasted on
me because i can eat like one plate and
i'm just like nope i'm gonna barf
thank you aaron
it says love the new channel jenny
oh thank you
i can't okay you can read that are those
scare salon shirts soft like snake
pliskin shirt love the design i'm not
entirely sure because i'm going through
red bubble which i've never used before
so
i'm going to try like tomorrow i want to
order some of the stuff because i have a
new site coming out to
um
probably at the beginning of august
which is all a true crime and i'm gonna
have some shirts from there too and so
i'm gonna get like one of each and see
what they're like i'm just gonna do
shirts and mugs
and like stickers and [ __ ] i'm not do
they have a million other things but i'm
not gonna bother with all that so i'm
gonna order some and see what they're
like and then wear them on the show and
give my opinion on them because
but redbubble is good because it seems
to have like a lot of different options
too i think you can get it on like
several different options
at least that's what i could determine
because we don't print those i just i
just do those through a red bubble
um
but yeah thank you very much i mean i'm
having a good time doing it i'm you know
i'm uh
it's cool to like just be able to like
focus on like some horror [ __ ] that i
have been wanting to do and like i said
i'm gonna do a true crime one as well
and i'm gonna start putting up videos
for that too and that's gonna be like a
whole new channel but
we'll see how it goes we'll see how it
goes
aaron says awesome let me know on one of
the next shows oh i definitely will yeah
because i i want to order some of the
shirts for myself so i can wear them on
the shows and
see how they come out i'm kind of still
[ __ ] around with the designs you know
because because i'm not sure how they're
going to look like when i [ __ ] print
the [ __ ] so
[Music]
murder hornets say if you don't have ac
here you die
i mean pretty much here as well i i
don't think i would like not having ac
here but yeah so
tom gets all-you-can-eat mahi-mahi
he actually he did good he ate a basket
of
the fried mahi mahi and a thing of
french fries and then he got like
another
serving
which how many more pieces was it
four four pieces oh yeah they would have
kept feeding me but it's like fishing's
chips just yeah british fish and chips
except it's mahi tuna
no to mahi's not tuna i'm the neptunian
a different is a different thing
it has a texture like tuna though yeah
it's kind of uh
more solid i would i don't want to say
dry but
more of a meaty type texture it's not
really light and flaky i mean what was
it like
12.99 so that's like all you can eat we
see the trough
which is
bad the trough
you guys can [ __ ] google it it's
called troff
yeah the trough or the oyster trough the
oyster trough
it looks like a dump but it looks like
dump it does on that
but it's not
it's just
on the inside it's nice
and see when i was at the oasis you know
at the biker bar
i asked them it says where do you get
where do you get seafood around here
like oysters and they go and they just
looked at me like i was [ __ ] crazy
the trough duh yeah this is the trough
and it says yeah you go to the trough
and they and and
you know how are the prices and they're
like you go in there and you get the
specials and it's going to be the market
price and then what what they're trying
to get rid of
so sometimes and and they they were
baiting me there's sometimes you can get
all you can eat deep fried oysters for
20 bucks
big ones something like that
and i was like oh with the lemon butter
and everything well for [ __ ] 20 bucks
oh [ __ ] man i could eat i could eat deep
fried oysters yeah tom could demolish
that [ __ ] tomorrow's always just
so i went down there to go see it
and it is kind of a biker hangout
there's motorcycles there [ __ ] if
during motorcycle days and hours there's
gonna be harleys and stuff out there
it's like a bar
yeah they got they got a full bar it's
like yeah it's on the water so it looks
like you're on the beach but it's not
that's a lake i think
and uh
so it's got like a big huge lake behind
it
boats
and uh
it's bright in there it's not dark like
a bar but it's it's bright
kind of like a beach bar
a lot of glass it's very florida very
florida
very florida very um how would i say oh
i want to say white trash i'm just
saying it's country
kind of yeah i mean it's kind of white
trash but not an enterogram it's not a
derogatory way in a good way
it's kind of
in the it's i don't want to say it's in
a rough part of town it's in the old
part of town
little bitty houses
um
it's just
old 50s looking you know it's like
you're at the beach
yeah i think all those houses around
there are from the 50s and 60s yeah i
mean because they look a lot like my
grandmother's house where i grew up and
some houses i where i grew up in daytona
and they were usually built in the 50s
and they don't look like a house you'd
live in they look like a house that
you'd buy
to go to the lake
but they are people are living in them
just these guys little concrete houses
little concrete houses concrete block so
um the trough is um
about
high quality
and value it's good food real good
cooked well
and you're buying they do have a set
menu and that's good too i've had stuff
off that menu
but
i prefer to just go in there and ask the
waitress
what it is they're trying to get rid of
what their specials are and today was
that body and it was good
yeah man he was just sitting there he
had like tartar sauce on the side of his
mouth the whole time he's like french
fries the french fries were [ __ ]
perfect
yeah
and you had the malt vinegar [ __ ]
lemon
fresh
tartar sauce they made that tartar sauce
that's not
yeah that's one of their things they
make their own tartar sauce too and
everything is [ __ ] battered right
there and it's it's regulars
they you know they come up and shake
your hand thank you for coming you know
well and i noticed that i mean we got
there kind of early so it wasn't there
wasn't that many people there but the
people that came in i noticed that the
woman that was the waitress her name was
brandy by the way i saw it on the thing
yeah um she knew everyone's name she's
like hey charlie like when they came in
so she knew everybody that came in there
yeah so it's like repeat customers i've
been all over the united states been in
[ __ ] several different continents
i'm a trained cook among other things
you know what i mean kind of like
[ __ ]
i could have been a special forces guy
on a [ __ ] battleship along with this
other dude who was a [ __ ] new orleans
cook
uh during a movie called under siege i
could have been that but i'm not that
anyway you know
imagine if that [ __ ] showed up
cigal
you know we needed a card we need a
but in his like current fat days we need
a we need a cardboard cut out of him
sitting
yes sitting his fat ass down that would
be so funny so maybe now that i have a
maybe i can make one
so i'm gonna make one
i was uh
excuse me
i was trying to think of what that would
what that meal would have cost me in um
downtown new york
last time i was there
like in 2012
that fish
with especially with the uh
with the with the uh with the extra
servings that i got
they would charge 100 bucks for that
easily in in new york
especially in that
in that motif
like if you go to new york and try to
bring a florida beach restaurant
to new york where you had it where
everything looked [ __ ] authentic and
everything it would they would pay a lot
of money to go to that
would they or would they just be like
[ __ ] this no
they paid money to go to that
because
in boston there was a restaurant in
[ __ ] harvard square
called davis square called red bones and
red bones was a southern restaurant they
paid a [ __ ] ton of money to go to a
southern restaurant
and i used to go there all the time it
was good food but it wasn't that
authentic but they had hus puppies in
there
pulled pork
catfish
and they tried to make it like a
southern
motif in there like a
restaurant with a saloon
or a bar on it
it was very popular in in the late 90s
mid to late 90s that place
i mean that was a long time ago yeah but
in those days yeah they've spent a lot
of money to go to those places hush
puppies yeah no you know they were
[ __ ] collared greens
it was did they have fried green
tomatoes they had fried drinking
tomatoes yeah
yeah
they had all kinds of different hot
sauces and stuff stuff that you wouldn't
really have in the south but you know
they thought it was southern
good i mean i just got i mean as much as
i was kind of into like all you can eat
mahi mahi for like 12.99 i'm like wow
that's a good deal but
the thing about it is that it's just
kind of like every time we go to koi wan
which is all you can eat you know
chinese buffet i'm just kind of like in
a way i kind of feel like it's because i
can't really eat that much like in one
sitting
so i was like as much as i would like to
have that yeah i'm not gonna get that so
what i got was i actually got they have
a really nice like fish sandwich they'll
put like a big [ __ ]
plank of like fish on the bread and it
has like nice tomatoes and it comes with
fries and everything and i was like well
i got that one time but i made the
mistake of getting it fried which was
delicious but i couldn't finish it and
then i felt kind of ill afterwards yeah
so today i got it broiled
and it was
perfect it was just enough food that i
felt
full but not like i was gonna heft you
know what i mean like that i was gonna
hurt afterward so that was good yeah
fried i love fried food
but fried food does not love me back it
adds a lot of calories and a lot of mass
does not love me back you can't eat as
much of it
every time we go because every now and
then we'll get like a wild hair and
we'll be like let's go to like red
lobster or something like that we'll go
to red lobster and it's like yeah yeah
and it's like yeah and it's decent like
if you want because there's not like a
lot of seafood options right you know it
close by
or there wasn't like back where we
usually there is now there is now
because we live kind of like by the way
that's here and there's by the country
but yeah so i'd go to like red lobster
and it's like and it would be really
good but then like as soon as i'd
finished eating i'm like oh man i think
you're gonna barf because it's just like
all fried even when i tried to get
stuff that wasn't fried
even they would still have enough fried
things on there that it would just be
like my stomach would just be rebelling
like the whole time afterwards yeah but
when you go to a place like the trough
that's where the locals go all right
um you want to do the specials
because what's happening is is if you're
ever been to food service
uh seafood does not have a long storage
life it's gotta go
okay and when
lifespan starts going down to days
you're gonna have to run a special and
get rid of that [ __ ]
and that's what that mahi was all about
they were trying to get rid of that they
were asking you once or more and want
some more said i can't eat anymore
i can't eat anymore
but that would have been a hundred
dollars worth of fish in new york
you did eat a lot of fish yeah that'd
been a hundred dollars would fit because
they gave you a big thing of a big pile
and then they gave you another and new
york's got great food so does boston
okay so i know the i know what i'm
talking about
uh
new york's got great [ __ ] jewish food
like [ __ ] can kanish
and [ __ ] you know what i mean they're
little matzah soups and [ __ ] you know
they got well all the all the
like
deli
same stuff yeah real good jellies and
they got fantastic pizza honestly the
best yeah
my favorite place that i ate when i was
in new york because i've been to new
york city like several times the my
favorite place i don't know if it's
still there is uh palm frite yeah that
is uh belgian twice fried
uh fries french fries and they would
just give them to you in a cone
and their whole thing
was that was it but then they'd have
like
40 different
dipping sauces yeah um
so i would go and it was cheap so they
had like a [ __ ] line around the like
all around the block
so you had to like get there and wait
but they'd give you like it was four
dollars for this massive cone and this
is like years ago i think it was 2009.
and they give you this massive cone of
like these twice flat fried um
french fries like you know
and then you'd get it with like i
usually got it with curry ketchup but
you could get it with like tons of other
stuff too and that [ __ ] was so [ __ ]
delicious and you just like walk around
the streets and eat it
so so cheap and that was like your your
food for the day man yeah cause it's a
whole cone of carbs yeah you didn't need
anything else the rest of the day
a lot of new yorkers moving here a lot
of our friends are new little smoke my
buddy here he's from new york he's from
manhattan
uh imani i thought he was from upstate
new york no he was from manhattan didn't
you say he was from manhattan i thought
he was i thought it was upstairs yeah i
think man i don't remember what he said
well i think he moved all over the place
but he you know i think he mostly claims
manhattan john gore said that's off
saint mark's i think it is yeah
i don't know if it's still there i mean
i went there
i was in new york last time
2009 2010 something like that and it was
still there then because i ate there but
other than that i don't know what what
happened what i was gonna say now imani
is a little bit of an exception because
she has the palette of a damn child i
mean [ __ ] she'll eat raw hot dogs
hopefully she's not listening [ __ ] i
used to do that when i was a kid
i took her to an indian restaurant she
didn't know what to do she said what
what she was doing she got taken masala
she can just can't feed her or anything
but little slow and a lot of other new
yorkers they love it here okay uh
there's a lot to do here that you really
can't do too much in new york if you're
from upstate new york you like it a lot
lil swole also has um
eating issues yeah a little swollen got
a eating issue he's he's he's a super
taster he can't eat anything that has
any flavor which he's a weird dude yeah
he eats everything he he can only like
stuff that's bland but there is a trend
with uh
uh
italian new yorkers italian american new
yorkers and i do agree with them they
when they come here they complain they
can't get pizza and yeah no you can't
yeah florida is you can get okay people
it's corporate pizza but you can't get
fantastic pizza unless you guys you're
not gonna be able to get new york ethnic
style [ __ ] pizza which i've had that
and to me it's it's some it's a little
it's similar to boston pizza a good
boston pizza is similar to that and
they're gonna be fighting oh no
it yes good boston pizza's about like
good new year like all but it's not that
[ __ ] great okay you're not that
[ __ ] italian you're just not okay
i'm a irish and i can [ __ ] make
badass [ __ ] pizza make the dough make
the sauce everything grow the damn
tomatoes out of the yard yeah you can
okay
i can make [ __ ] fantastic pizza with
the right dough everything
cook that [ __ ] on stone and everything
if you're that much
of a [ __ ]
guido
you can't live here because the p if
you're that if you're that [ __ ]
italian then you should be making your
own guys make your pizza make your own
make your own [ __ ] pizza well i kind
of feel like yeah that's kind of the
thing that i mean
well i don't know if i say it's not that
hard it just takes a lot of
it takes time it's going to take you
about a year to get that dough right
yeah
but the thing about it is that even okay
pizza is still pretty good yeah i mean
you can't mess it up too bad right so
right but i mean if you want like
sublime pizza it's going to take you
better then it takes you a while to like
figure out how to do it okay but you you
can get it right it's just trial and
error
and even the errors are edible
but it's going to take you about a year
of knowing how to think how it feels and
how the
what you want to use bread flour don't
using that [ __ ] up
all purpose but you want to use bread
flour high gluten bread flour
you want to learn how to use [ __ ]
yeast culture properly you want to learn
about delayed fermentation let that [ __ ]
ferment for at least 24 hours there's
all different kinds of things that a
[ __ ] [ __ ] is supposed to know
okay and you want to cook on [ __ ]
stone
in that oven
hot as possible
so 550 if you can get 550 then that's
what you did yeah i think 525 is as hot
as our oven goes but we leave it on for
like an hour and that stone's got to be
preheated for an hour it's got to be
[ __ ] hot all right
and you got to have a peel and you got
which is how to get the things off but
you're italian if you're that italian
then you can't [ __ ] leave [ __ ]
new york because of the pizza then you
you should be italian enough to [ __ ]
make a pizza make your own pizza right
[Laughter]
i mean if that's the only reason that's
right okay but i understand i mean
because i will agree that i mean and i'm
not saying there's there's some mom and
pop like pizza places
uh i haven't made any pizza places
around here better ones around but
better ones i've been to some okay ones
in orlando that were actually like
pretty decent
yeah that were like mom-and-pop now
you're gonna be dealing with [ __ ]
pizza hut and papa john's and dominoes
and honestly i you know i'm not proud
i'm used to those but i've ordered
domino's uh because domino's is very
very close to here so it's like if i
order food out i usually get from them
because but i don't usually get pizza i
usually get like a sandwich now i heard
a pizza store salad i heard i heard some
orlando area pizza stories that there
used to be some really good
new york style
pizzeria sit down pizzerias
they used the right [ __ ] buffalo type
mozzarella and everything you know
where's [ __ ] good cheese but over
time they didn't survive
and it's because
the clientele here in in florida
doesn't have a discerning palette for
pizza
so they didn't really see the difference
between that pizza and a papa john's
they just go for the papa john's yeah
so like look i'm just want to order
something for my kids swim team yeah so
it didn't survive in the market
so you have to make it yourself
but if you're that [ __ ] italian you
can make it i can make my own brand
pasta
okay i make my own pasta i haven't been
made in a while
even make my own ravioli and tortellini
haven't done all that [ __ ] in a while
but that's labor intensive [ __ ]
i was watching this this one girl
because like i said i get i got for
whatever reason i got like super
obsessed with these few channels that
do these kind of like budget challenges
and stuff
and one thing that a lot of them do is
that
if they're trying to eat
from they're like okay we're gonna eat
for 15 a week
from
the dollar store or whatever one thing
that they'll do is they're like we're
gonna get a big [ __ ] five pound bag
of flour for like a dollar a dollar
twenty five and they will make
everything out of that they will make
bread they will make pasta actually the
one girl that i watch i think she's
called that lisa dawn
and um she even makes uh she has what is
the um
what's the pasta called that has it's
like kind of like a little
long thing like that that has like
little ridges on it oh she has like a
little uh
she has like a little maker for that so
she even has like the little rod she
like cuts it out into little squares and
like flip it on there and does a little
bit and then like throws them all in the
pot and stuff like that so like yeah if
you i mean obviously pasta dried pasta
is pretty cheap to buy but they're like
if you're really really fun to save
money you can buy a five pound bag of
flour and you can make a lot of pasta
with it flour eggs oil there there it is
just throw it on a table yeah that's
that's that's your noodles
yeah i mean you can
yeah and she makes her she usually makes
her own um spaghetti as well
hang it up let it dry a little bit yeah
there's some pasta presses you can go
through it's a little thing you can put
in there and you can get whatever we
have one of those supplements i got two
that's right because i gave you one one
yeah for christmas you can make sheets
of it to do lasagna or you can [ __ ]
change the change the spacing of the
blades
to make fettuccine or linguine or
[ __ ] angel hair you can do everything
if you want to put
spinach water in it you can make it
green tomato water to make it red
there's a bunch of stuff you can do
or spinach water i feel like they make
spinach pasta as well that's what i said
spinach water
i thought you said tomato water twice i
spent spinach water and then tomato
water danny rowling said rigatone yeah
it might be rigatoni but it comes it's
like a little thing she has
it's like this wooden it's nice i don't
know where i don't remember where she
said she got it but it's like this
little um like wooden block that has all
these like raised
little spikes on it and then she has
like a little rod and she cuts the
dough into little squares and then she
rolls it around the rod and then rolls
it across the thing and it makes little
and then she'll freeze it until like she
needs to use it but yeah she's like man
if you're
yeah it takes some time
but
it's super cheap and you can make like a
lot of and obviously you can make your
own bread too and now i i feel like that
one bread recipe that you don't even
need to like
knead it or like anything like that
went around tik tok and instagram and
everything like that like a super easy
yeah i think i feel like it was almost
was it like a soda bread
oh slides in there what's up sly
rigatoni is a large tube yeah this was
kind of like a little like about the
size of your pinky like a tube and then
it had like ridges around it
i don't remember if it was rigatoni or
not brace versus said slow down i'm
writing this down
john smith said the irony is that in
naples
pizza is con regarded pretty much as
beggar's food yeah it's cheap yeah i
mean the thing about it is that pizza in
the u.s is kind of like it's a lot
different than what our pizza originally
started out as
we saw um i think oracle recommended it
right the the show that was on
history channel
and we watched it on hulu i think the
food that made america and they did like
a whole show about pizza kind of like
and they went into like the history of
italian-american food
is an elevated version of italian
peasant food
when italian immigrants came here
from their point of view
even back in the 20s america was a
[ __ ] land of plenty compared to what
they were used to
they could get their hands on vegetables
and they could get their hands on things
that they just they just
in in greater quantities that they
couldn't get back in italy
so everything started to become
exaggerated
when you make a pizza
instead of just putting some slices of
tomato on it
and maybe a little bit of cheese you put
tomato sauce on it and a whole bunch of
cheese and then toppings
you know then you start [ __ ] around
with the dough and it's all local
chicago pizza new york pizza you know
it's they all had different yeah chicago
kind of makes more like pizza casserole
yeah although i'm not hating i like that
too
they don't have it's all good chicago
was deep dish it's all good and then
there was pizza pie which had an upper
crust and a lower crust yeah and there's
even that's all
that's also good detroit pizza square
cooked and [ __ ] yeah cast iron
also
pretty much all pizza is good so there's
a bunch of different
bunch of different versions of american
italian american pizza and it's all
based on location and those italians
would fight over it
over who had the better versions
they're all good they're all just their
own different
yeah for interpretations of that there's
no need to fight yeah it's all delicious
back in italy
pizza was more kind of like what we
would call focaccia yeah it's more like
that yeah which is just bread with some
seasoning and which is also good
tomatoes maybe some cheese and it's just
kind of like
also like focaccia really
but here
especially during the [ __ ] 20s during
the roaring 20s when
italians really started to make money
because the industry started to pick up
and then you had bootlegging and there
was
you know you don't want to say well they
were all gangsters no they all wished
they were gangsters but [ __ ]
but uh there started to be a lot more
money and more status in the italian
community italian american community
well they started to exaggerate that
damn
food that where these where pizza
evolved into a [ __ ] meal a meal for a
whole [ __ ] family [ __ ] it it's a meal
for an extended family
like a like like thanksgiving dinner you
know it was like that that's what level
you're talking about please tell me
somebody somewhere has made a
thanksgiving dinner pizza yeah it should
have been
i would be i'll be very disappointed if
i find out that nobody has thought of
that
not traced it back
through food lore
me being a [ __ ] great student of food
history
pizza was made famous by gangsters
pretty much yeah it really did help yeah
because
you had a situation where
the newspapers wanted to talk about
[ __ ]
scarface what's his name
all i can think of is al pacino
and they would go on and they would
mention they would talk about al capone
and everybody knew he was [ __ ]
bootlegger but they couldn't really see
that in the newspaper they're trying to
do a puff piece on al capone here he is
and they would italian obviously talking
about this exotic food hanging out in
this exotic italian restaurant where
only italians hung out they made he ate
this exotic food
called pizza
which is hilarious but it it really was
only they knew about it like a century
ago yeah that's a century ago literally
and pizza was like some big exotic
italian thing that like other people
didn't eat and then they would do an
interview with al capone about
pizza and he would go oh yeah chicago
pizza is the best pizza [ __ ] new york
and there's got the best pizza yeah [ __ ]
new york and their pizza that's [ __ ]
weak man weak sauce pizza you know so
there was from the very beginning
[ __ ] rivalry between these cities
which like i said it's ridiculous
because it's all good yeah it's all good
people just want to [ __ ] i think they
were just i think they were playing
around well yeah people just want to
fight about stupidity they were just
playing around i'm just like look it's
all good
i'll eat i'll eat any of it seriously
it's just funny to think that something
so ubiquitous as pizza
yeah was
only a century ago yeah
considered like ethnic food yeah which
is like that's super fun
america and those italian americans are
a testament
to global culture because it was their
version of pizza that marched across the
world and took tried to take over
that was italian american pizza
that conquered the world not italian
pizza
you go to italy and get good pizza it's
gonna be like focaccia yeah which like i
said that's good too
i like i also like that you go anywhere
in central and south america even down
in brazil it's [ __ ] a copy of an
american pizza yeah
now i might say something that's gonna
be kind of controversial because i know
american pizza and actually it's not
just american pizza because i've seen
some other
even some other pizzas that are offered
by the chains like pizza hut or dominoes
or something like that in other parts of
the world like new zealand or whatever
um sometimes they have like way more
excessive pizzas than we have in the us
i'm like bro okay
but just dial that back but um
i kind of like
i don't like pizzas with a whole bunch
of [ __ ] on it i don't like the meat
lovers
uh
i mean i know you do it's well i i'm not
into it it just gives me heartburn it's
too much i can go across i can go across
the [ __ ] globe from simple to very
[ __ ] complex
i mean i'll eat anything it's all good
it's all good
but if i'm ordering a pizza for myself
i kind of prefer
honestly i kind of prefer no meat
i kind of prefer veggie i like spinach i
like mushrooms i like if you break it
down to peppers if you deconstruct pizza
it's a sandwich that's all it is
pretty much it's an italian cheese
sandwich
a piece of focaccia is like an italian
cheese sandwich
you know i mean instead of american
cheese instead of american bread it's
italian bread with some italian cheese
and some oil and some herbs on it that's
focaccia maybe some sliced tomatoes
it's open-faced though it doesn't have
two sides yes open-faced sandwich and
you can eat it with your hand like a
burger or a sandwich that's all it is
yeah
and then it evolved from that
you know you're putting meat on it like
a sandwich meat cheese with tomato like
a sandwich
it's a sandwich
but it's open-faced and it's got it's
round you cut it into slices or it's
square and then you cut it into squares
it comes off a stone or it comes out of
cast iron it's a
it's like a grilled cheese sandwich
yeah it's big so it's a great idea
it's an italian-american version of a
[ __ ] hamburger
it's genius i mean
how can you not love bread and cheese
yeah and meat
and meat if you want yeah or like i said
yeah bread cheese meat honestly i can
eat
i can eat pizza without meat on it i you
know like i said i'm not a i like
pepperonis but i'm not a big fan that's
like probably one of the last things i'd
pick one because they give me heartburn
yeah but
um
if i'm ordering a pizza for myself i
usually get mushrooms and
peppers
or mushrooms and onions i don't usually
get meat on it i'll eat it if it has me
know i'm not gonna lie but
i don't know i kind of like simpler
pizzas honestly when we used to go i
don't is it still even open there like
when we used to go to eye bar the pizza
place that was around the corner from
eye bar where i bar used to be yeah yeah
i used to call it men's deep dish yeah
he died didn't he he died he did he he
lived a full life though he did that he
was an old man yeah the guy that ran it
he used to call him deep dish i just
call him deep dish i don't remember what
his real name was yeah he was a nice guy
though yeah yeah he like i called him
deep dish yeah he thought that was super
funny yeah yeah but yeah deep dish the
pizza gangster
he likes that's right or is it a greek
i thought he was greek but he might have
been greek i think he was greek yeah but
yeah we used to go there sometimes
because he was a genius because that
pizza place had been there for like 100
years and it is cause it's around the
corner from the club yeah and it was
open all night so all the drunk people
would come out of the club and be like
oh pizza but honestly my favorite pizza
of theirs was their white pizza with
like just hunks of tomatoes on it yeah
man that [ __ ] was delicious
yeah because it's simple you could taste
everything camp guys there's a lot of
pizza and better call saul and breaking
bad i haven't seen either one of them i
got to see him yeah yeah
danny rowling said jenny did you finish
the latest season of stranger things if
so would you i haven't finished it yet
seriously i watched the first four
episodes and i keep meeting to get back
to it and i just haven't had time to so
don't tell me what happened snatched it
was talking about al capone's vault yeah
we we we talked to we mentioned that
yeah they're doing that geraldo yeah
john gore said nothing like cold pizza
and hot coffee for breakfast i mean cold
pizza is just so good
honestly a cold pizza is good and you
know what is even better than that cold
fried chicken now they're talking about
how good anchovies are i've heard that
man but they say you can't fight the
anchovies you just have to roll with it
it's a certain
flavor that makes all pizza taste better
but man i just i just can't i just can't
bring myself to do it
well and come up with it the weird thing
about anchovies i don't think i've ever
at least knowingly eating a pizza that
anchovies on it but you eat anchovies
all the time without knowing about it
because a lot of salad dressings have
anchovies yeah yeah in it that's why
they always like tell you
if you're a vegan then you have to look
at the ingredients because it might have
anchovies in there i'm not averse to
anchovies i love fish i love pretty much
anything that comes out of the ocean
within reason i will eat it
but
i don't know it's just not something
that i usually think of as a pizza
topping like i said i usually if i'm
getting a pizza i usually like something
with minimal toppings and the toppings
are usually vegetables
like i said usually i'll get i love
mushrooms on pizza i like hunks of
tomato
i like minimal sauce i'm not really
unless the sauce is sweeter because like
i said if the sauce is acidic
heartburn so i have to get like sweeter
sauce
i like a little bit less sauce lots of
cheese
maybe big hunks of tomatoes
uh i like bell peppers and i like
mushrooms i also like pineapple on there
but you know that's it's you know i can
have that or not it's not my favorite
but and i'll eat it with p with meat on
it but
i don't know this whole meat lovers
thing i can't man i can't
i can't deal with that it's too much
it's too much i can't taste each thing
i like to be able to taste each thing
i don't know i'm weird like that i've
been like that since i was a kid it's
just kind of like even when i was a kid
you know people would be like hey let's
put gravy on the [ __ ] i'm like don't put
gravy on the [ __ ] i just want to like
i want to taste the [ __ ] i don't want to
taste the gravy you know what i mean
i don't like too many things going on i
don't like too many things going on
slash fred says if you guys ever see
that movie return of the killer tomatoes
they had a pizza place in that movie
honestly we still haven't done attack of
the killer tomatoes
um
one of these days we'll maybe we should
do like a twofer
of both of those because i haven't seen
return of the killer tomatoes in a long
time
picture says cold chicken for the win oh
my god
cold fried chicken
i mean hot fried chicken is good too but
man cold fried chicken
it's so much better because it's just
it's all like congealed and it's not
messy
man no it's good cold fried chicken is
so good i like hot fried chicken with
[ __ ] waffles in the [ __ ] well
that's good too maple syrup that's good
too and butter that's good too yeah but
i'm just saying that
as far as cold foods go like you know
foods that are also good hot
but that you can eat for breakfast the
next day when you're perhaps hungover
yeah
um cold pizza is good
cold fried chicken i would argue is
better
depending on where the pizza came from
and depending where the chicken came
from
but i really do like cold fried chicken
and honestly like publix
they've got your back on this because
they will sell you hot fried chicken in
the deli and then in this little deli
case over here they got cold
fried chicken like tenders and stuff
like that which are delicious so they
know what they're doing
dicker says he's not sure if he likes
the seafood or the tartar sauce
you got to come to a good place man
you would have liked it today or with
the trough
with that all you could eat
mahi
[ __ ] fish and chips
and that's homemade tartar sauce
and they were giving it in big old
buckets
and i was thinking to myself you know
this isn't uh too unhealthy for my diet
but then i'm looking at those [ __ ]
buckets of tartar sauces that give me i
go yeah it's about a thousand calories
it probably is
i didn't well you went through like two
because and you were trying to give me
your tartar sauce and i'm like dude they
gave me one thing of tartar sauce i'm
like i didn't even finish that they're
handed out [ __ ] they're handing out that
scoops of tartar sauce like it's a
[ __ ] scoop of ice cream because look
i like tartar sauce yeah i do
but i like a little bit of tartar sauce
like i said i like i wanted to enhance
the flavor i don't want to overwhelm
this is good tartar sauce that [ __ ]
cold
thick
creamy rich tartar sauce homemade tartar
sauce mixture of mayonnaise and sour
cream
with the onion
and the pickle
yeah oh yeah although there's a little
bit of sugar in it i could taste there's
a little bit of sugar a little there was
yeah to make it bright and shiny oh man
to be honest though um for seafood i
could take or leave tartar sauce tartar
sauce is good
but if you don't have it that's fine um
i'm a big cocktail sauce fan i like
coffee yeah i like that too
but um
with fried fish tart
[ __ ] right yeah the british got that
right
well they're more there are more malt
vinegar yeah well i had that too i
really do not like malt vinegar i gotta
say i was putting that on there and the
tartar sauce yeah the british have
tartar sauce
they do yeah yeah i'm just saying they
invented that
yeah yeah i'm not saying they didn't i'm
just saying if you go to like a fish and
chip place most people
as far as as you know in my experience
uh were malt vinegar people yeah and i
malt vinegar is like okay it's a little
sour for me
i don't know i'm not into it like i said
tartar sauce is
good that's like middle of the road um
for seafood it's either nothing because
i want to taste the seafood or
cocktail sauce i like that horseradish i
like that that's good
okay so what do you guys want to talk
about
well that's what we've been talking
about talking about food they're talking
about food everybody's talking about
food they're still in there talking
about food well yeah okay everybody
wants to talk about food you know how
that goes all right
all right john goes who were the tartars
though were they russian muslims or
turks or something yeah they were
something like that
why is that even called tartar sauce
i need to look into everything the
tardis evidently the tartars
um were kind of like uh
kind of like warriors on horseback
and they did weird things like evidently
put meat on raw meat underneath their
saddles and wrap around yeah i heard
about that and then i'm cooking the meat
with my ass it was kind of like
with all the acids from the horse and
the salt and the heat
the who knows it was probably
weather was probably cool so it probably
wouldn't work here in florida it should
just rot
the [ __ ] flies that get on it
well yeah like within
five seconds yeah or roaches yeah
and then evidently they could take that
meat out from there and um
wash it off
and uh eat it raw
well if you sliced it thinly enough yeah
it probably would yes steak tartare yeah
you know you could eat it which i've
always kind of i don't think i've ever
eaten steak tartare but that always
sounded like fascinating it's good
because you'd like it well yeah
what do i tell you every single time you
make beef
make it raw just run a match under that
[ __ ] well that would be what we call
steaks burgers stuff like that i just
want i want that [ __ ] red and mushy in
the middle and bloody well you can eat
uh raw hamburger i know yeah i mean they
don't they don't advise it because
i mean steak it's not as big a deal
because like it's better but they you
know when they grind up meat for ground
they were like well we can't guarantee
like where all this meat came from so
you gotta get real quick to be on the
safe side um probably you should cook
this through but i'm like [ __ ] that i
really really like
i know it's weird but i really really
like ever since i was a kid
super rare steak super rare
hamburgers well you'd like tartar yeah i
probably they always say well you guys
got to be checked by this no
it's just a good cut of meat and it's
inspected by a chef who knows what to
look for to make sure everything's fresh
and if there aren't any parasites in it
and it has to be cut the right way to
make it nice
to chew
and i had to do some research to see
what it is but i can make it for you
it's it's it's not that big of a deal
now oh maybe you should yeah it's gonna
be cut kind of thin
um now some people
some people will like you eat it with
vinaigrettes
where the vinegar itself kind of
chemically cooks it after you yeah i've
heard that dip it in there you know i
don't know whatever we'll see texture i
mean it'd be chewy
it'd be good to have that as an option i
kind of want to try it both ways yeah
because i've always kind of wanted to
because i know this is i'm not a vampire
or anything but it's like
even when i was a little kid i would
like go through the grocery store and i
would look at like all the raw beef and
i'm like man i could eat it like that
it um
it looks so good it was kind of reminded
me of cured meat like ham
yeah like that okay it's not that it's
not as exotic as you think
no i know you're like oh okay well like
i said i've eaten
steak that was
pretty much like red all the way through
i've eaten burgers that were red all the
way through yeah it's not really like
that though and that shit's delicious
closer to like cured meat or sushi
okay that's good too like that that's
fine a little chewy
a little chewier
danny rowling is really trying to get
you to put on that white matthias ain't
worried about that [ __ ] wig come on
danny he even told you to put it in the
freezer and then it would and then it
would make you cooler if you put it on
just saying
yeah why the white one well you haven't
worn it in a while he's got some kind of
fetish going on i don't remember where
it's at it's like it's in the closet i
might have thrown it up on the top shelf
though because i was cleaning out all
the wigs in there because you just throw
things all over the closet i don't see
the white one
look up on the look up on the
shelf
yeah it's way up there
well you don't wear it that much so i
just chucked it up there i put all my
wigs that i wear like on the
at ground level
do you know
spaghetti pizza says sly yeah [ __ ] in
i don't think i've ever had spaghetti
pizza
i mean i would eat it not gonna lie but
all right
there you go
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
you need to brush that [ __ ]
i just pulled it out of the closet
yeah clearly
okay
now look at one of the damn founding
fathers that's right like some
[ __ ] that's on the money give me
yeah give me a profile like you're on
the money
look all like stern and stuff there you
go nice
look all official
you gotta brush wigs though
earlier i put this wig on before we did
the show
and i have i don't know like you guys
pookie has commandeered my regular ass
brush so i had to buy another brush
for in there
so i'm brushing my wig and she runs in
the bathroom and jumps on the toilet and
jumps up on the sink and is like
mommy you are not allowed to brush your
own hair
you have to brush pookie's hair
no they're saying it looks like this
barrister yeah there you go that's a
lawyer in it
yeah essentially yeah
[Laughter]
now i'm here to pass judgment on a
[ __ ] do a british accent i can't
do a british accent
[Music]
uh grant there's oh grantham's has some
ideas for us to talk about
talk about
number one best childhood friend and
what they are doing now
i know he's trying to bait me into some
[ __ ] best movie ever filmed in florida
okay how to make a pile of money on
youtube yeah i wish
famous goths in movies and music who
aren't fake okay
best childhood friend and what they're
doing now
um
my best childhood friend
was a girl named
shelly what was her last name
mcgee
or something yeah i think
i don't remember where i met her now i
think that her mom and my mom
work together like in a in an accounting
office
i think this was a long time ago so i'm
not like remembering all that good
i remember her coming over to our house
we lived in a townhouse at that time
and i remember the two of us
um
building a sled out of cardboard and
like going down the [ __ ] staircase
which we thought was super fun
um
but i don't know what she's doing now i
haven't seen her in like probably
[ __ ] 30 or 40 years
so i don't know but she was like my best
friend in school i do still remember her
name and i kind of remember what she
looked like but i don't really remember
anything else about her
best movie ever filmed in florida gator
gator white lightning
um
i don't know man i can't think of a lot
of like movies all i can think of i can
think it was shitty movies that were
filmed in florida
like um the blood waters of dr z
as or uh zayat if you would prefer i
think it's called that as well i
remember that being a shot in florida
man i can't really remember i can't
remember like good [ __ ] was that how to
make a pile of money on youtube like i
said i wish i knew
uh cause then i would be those days are
kind of gone
well i mean people still do make a
living at it
but
i mean it's harder there's a lot of
competition
and
i don't know i kind of feel like people
that are making a lot of money at it
or maybe doing [ __ ] that i wouldn't
really enjoy doing
you know what i mean
this is the kind of struggle that i've
had like throughout my life i'm just
kind of like well
i could you know we could
because tom is always kind of like hey
we could start a fight with another
channel or something it's like [ __ ] i
don't want to do that
i won't do that
it's like if i
if i had to do [ __ ] that i don't want to
do all the time just like make money on
youtube then i might as well just get a
regular ass job you know what i'm saying
i don't i don't know i enjoy it oh you
put it in your dancing wig
it's
this isn't the dancing wig i couldn't
find the dancing wig
oh that's is that mine this is yours
yeah
i was gonna say it's a little short
what did i do with your danzig wig i
don't know i either hung them up
because your danzig wig was all naughty
yeah and i was just kind of like you
gotta brush that that's not my job i'm
not the wig brusher
i pro i threw a lot of stuff like up on
the shelf like just to get them out of
the way i've kept my wigs down there
because i wear those all the time
i'm like the wig
it's in there somewhere i promise
is it no it's probably it's hanging on
check one of the hangers do you see well
i see someone slides a dancing wig but
it's got
wet red in it okay yeah i think i found
it yeah you found it i think i found it
the one with it right in it those are
just my ponytails my clip-in ponytails
yeah that's it
yeah it looks pretty skanky that's it
you gotta look like a [ __ ] when you put
the dancing wig on
well you'd know all about that man [ __ ]
[Laughter]
joshua says wait you're not a natural
blue i feel totally lucky
i should tell people that i have
naturally blue hair i need to go to the
club with this you know
yeah why don't you
what would they do
probably
oh tom yeah
like they usually do what did it stop
just calm down you have this
she's trying to fix it
okay there we go yeah there we go damn i
get hands on this [ __ ] where i
put the wig on
just wear that and tell everybody you're
in like a [ __ ] heavy metal yeah sure
my name is nigel harrison from the
inverted ashtrays there you go yeah yeah
um yeah so what were we talking about
yeah i had to make a pile of money on
youtube like i said i kind of feel like
maybe some people do
but
i don't know if i have to do a bunch of
[ __ ] i don't really want to do
then i would rather not
i mean it's nice just like doing this
i enjoy doing these i'm talking about
stuff i enjoy
if i had to do a bunch of stuff that i
don't enjoy then like i said i might as
well go get a regular [ __ ] job which
i don't want to do the most okay the
channels that make the most money
based upon my personal observations
are channels that are political and
funny
uh salty cracker who's this [ __ ]
crazy
white dude from
california with a mexican wife
who gets on there and just [ __ ] makes
fun of the news
and he's outrageous
he'll live stream he starts off on
youtube and then he moves to other ones
where he can [ __ ] get away with other
things like an hour two he always moves
into the other ones he'll make
a couple grand in a live stream in a
three hour livestream
yeah he makes a [ __ ] lot of money
but he's in california spending a lot of
money too
there's you know that economy is [ __ ]
up well then i've seen him get [ __ ]
thousand dollar super chats
just a single super chat come up
and he just 20s he'll get 20s just all
[ __ ] night long
and he's a funny channel it's called
salty cracker
[ __ ]
hilarious like i said i don't know it's
just kind of like
i don't know i i just don't love the
idea of like having to like pretend to
be something i'm not or
it just seems like exhausting
but he's not pretending he that is who
he is well yeah but like i'm not that
person yeah so it's just kind of like
he's i would rather just like be me and
it's like if people want to like watch
me yeah then that's cool
i'm not gonna like get all i don't need
to be a millionaire or anything like
that i'm just saying
you know
i just don't really want to have to do
[ __ ] because i really don't like thank
you very much victor
thank you here's a pile of quarters
nickels and dimes
thank you
that's the thing it's like i just
i worked like regular jobs like for
many many years and i hated it i just
really hate it
yeah and honestly if i could just like
talk to you guys and just like put up
videos about [ __ ] that i like yeah and
can make a living at it
then that's cool aaron says i'm going
for 30 minutes and tom's in a way
and i'm [ __ ] handsome i'm beautiful
as a [ __ ] yeah you leave i'm
ugly you come back i'm [ __ ] gorgeous
that's how that [ __ ] [ __ ] works you
should probably wear that all the time
although you should probably comb it
it'd be like fabio it's like fabio now
fabio fabio
i cannot believe it's not butter
i'm gonna show you that
i'm gonna show you that mst sketch that
they did about you well they did a fabio
kit
it came with the wig
and like a chest plate yeah
like some other stuff
fabio fabio it was so [ __ ] funny i
don't even remember what episode they're
saying funny
[ __ ] um
cab guy knows what's this i don't even
like sticks that much he's because it's
just regular politics
styx is an intelligent guy
but he can get
boring
but i like him i i like his paranormal
stuff too
um
yeah tim poole also makes mad bank
and he's a [ __ ] milk toast fence
sitter we know that because he doesn't
want to lose his channel but he's
actually a very good source
of commentary on the news and decent
analysis
on on general topics
there's some specialized topics i'll
recommend it
the duran
the duran it's [ __ ]
four or five guys from europe
and they will sit there and pick apart
geopolitics and what's happening in
eastern europe
especially with the um
with the ukraine war
and their [ __ ] track record of
predicting the future has been [ __ ]
great you want to check out the duran
and anyone associated with the duran all
their guests are [ __ ] top-notch
trying to think who else is good
thank you aaron
yeah for a glow up tom what's he saying
what's his name you're so beautiful i
know her look hit me up she don't say
that you need to [ __ ] hit me up
[ __ ] i just said that
yeah sitting here trying to [ __ ]
entertain but
um
[Laughter]
my only fans will be ready just for you
[ __ ] aaron i got some you keep
teasing the only thing yeah
when are you gonna do that he's gonna go
in his man cave with his laptop and he's
just gonna be like
oh [ __ ]
what
i didn't tell him
didn't tell him what i gotta offer to do
[ __ ] bachelorette parties
i forgot
that [ __ ] would [ __ ] go sideways on
the [ __ ] heartbeat you're gonna get
molest what yeah i thought you would
like that
i don't want to get in trouble with you
you know what i mean [ __ ]
attack but you don't care that if i get
attacked by a bunch of biker women
trying to set my dick and [ __ ] [ __ ]
me up there [ __ ] dancing like that i
ain't going to dance naked for the mole
[ __ ]
somebody at the oasis
yeah is having a bachelorette party at
the castle allegedly well it was and
there they tried to hire him as a dance
yeah it was one of the bartenders she's
she's a stripper she's an ex stripper
she's an extra she's trying to
that was that was that was amy
amy says [ __ ] you know i got a gig
for you at [ __ ] you know we got my
friends having a bachelorette party and
she and i and i'm gonna put you at the
top of the building [ __ ] cup and
[ __ ] she was gonna offer me 300.
and i said that's not bad
no
i got it for a couple hours
well yeah that is kind of far though
it's kind of far
[Laughter]
victor said don't do it tom you'll have
to keep the kid in florida
yeah
and and my [ __ ] my abs are not
[ __ ]
on point yet okay well maybe you could
paint something to like look like
you know how they do
i'm on a [ __ ] heavy cycle right now
[ __ ] normally i only my hrt
was only like 200 milligrams of [ __ ]
testosterone
testosterone a week i'm on like 700 now
and i threw indiana ball about 350 mil
uh 50 milligrams of [ __ ] 50
milligrams a day at the anna ball that's
one reason why i look so [ __ ]
bloated
right in my face
my face looks like a [ __ ] cherry pie
because he's the tom pie
deanna ball is [ __ ] five times more
anabolic than than than normal
testosterone it's super testosterone i
tried to [ __ ] her a couple days ago here
in front of this damn computer screen
she had to turn me down i was like
that's it i'm gonna get something it's
the middle of the day and i was like in
the middle of like working on my [ __ ]
was like [ __ ] three inches longer
than it should have [ __ ] been that
[ __ ] was super natural it was poking out
of the [ __ ] jeans i'm like i'm gonna
get some of this [ __ ] i was like and
she's like no i'm busy i'm busy
like dude it's the middle of the work
day i know [ __ ] what are you doing what
do you do there's women out there that
would pay and you were chewing gums with
my face yeah chewing gum and being bad
it was right after we got dolma stole my
gum yeah it was right after we got done
[ __ ] doing a video yeah we're doing a
video review i was like i'm waiting and
i'm looking at this [ __ ] these [ __ ]
titties and [ __ ]
[ __ ] she had her [ __ ] stockings on
and i'm going like i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm
gonna fluff this chick i'm gonna get
this
my mind is getting dirty and [ __ ] she
doesn't give a [ __ ] she's now totally
she totally just doesn't give a [ __ ] no
[ __ ] blue ball [ __ ] yeah
terrible i'm too old for this she's too
old for this [ __ ] man i gotta get i
gotta get like a second and third
girlfriend to [ __ ] pick up her slack
actually well they can't live here they
can as long as they don't live here
doesn't it amy amy [ __ ] the girl
who's who the girl i'm gonna show her to
you if you want to see her
the the the bartender [ __ ] down at
oasis saw you and she was oh she got
some big ass titties too she's i'm gonna
get that i like her [ __ ] why don't
you bring her down here because she's
trying to [ __ ] scope up on you too
and i [ __ ] you know what i mean we'll
see
you thought it's gonna be like a
throuple i always kind of feel like you
know what it would be funny like you
thought hey i'm gonna pick up like this
other chick or something like that and
then they come back and then they like
me better yeah but that might happen
i i gave it probably would i gave that
warning out to these yo because i mean
i gave that warning out to these young
men i'm like i'm super awesome we saw
that many times
that's happened many times in our
[ __ ] history with all our friends
[ __ ]
old [ __ ] player picks up a second
girlfriend and then that girl leaves him
for her yeah
it's like oh well she's cooler than yeah
[Laughter]
i kind of suspect that's probably what
would happen you would like to please
run off with her everybody would break
some chick home but i'd be like hey i
like this [ __ ] hey
she's kicking me out of my own house
and then we just like leave you behind
they go to restroom hold on we don't
need a dude come on
i kind of suspect that's probably what
would happen i suspect that's probably
what happened that's why i don't care
about it because i know that's what
would happen
uh danny rowling says biker women and
gods are the hottest in my opinion
i mean
we do all right we do it right but you
know what i mean even an old bat like me
uh john gore said this is a family show
it's really not
it's really not but you know
cam guy said i saw a youtube channel
where the guy goes around to homeless
encampments and gives out food and
hygiene stuff my wife said they throw
away lunch every day
brought in by the pharmaceutical sales
reps
i yeah i don't think i've ever seen that
uh channel
actually but that sounds kind of cool
uh
they eat a good bit of the food and then
they done at the end of the work day
three is a crowd it is
um you know
i think well the thing about it is that
i think a lot of dudes
you know just i don't know i'm just
generalizing i think a lot of dudes do
kind of have this
fantasy about us like oh there's gonna
be this other chick and she's gonna come
in it's gonna be this whole but it never
works out like the way you think it's
gonna work out you know it just it never
does we've seen it happen
many many times in our friend group
uh you can tell that the guy has like
designs he's like ooh i have like this
hot girlfriend but also this other hot
chick and it's like oh like the two hot
girlfriends are kind of into each other
oh i'm gonna like reap the benefits of
that
that's usually not how it works out
either one
uh
the chick gets pissed at the other one
and then like leaves the dude or the two
chicks run off together and leave the
dude alone so that's
all like 99 of the time that's what
happens so at least in my experience uh
you know i don't know but uh you know
um tom's about to be on that gary
ridgeway type [ __ ] because he is so
potent
awkward conversation this is your
brother eric by the way oh okay well
wait a minute i'm gonna have to have him
come back and ask what's that what's
what is him
patriots revenge says
awkward conversation this is your
brother eric by the way wait my brother
eric
is this my brother
oh [ __ ]
this is awkward that's funny
this is awkward
your brother's on is that you
seriously is that you are you are you
[ __ ] with me how are you [ __ ] with
me you gotta ask me questions
we're gonna prove it
prove that you're mean prove that prove
that you're related to me what did he
ask yes indeed he says oh [ __ ]
my brother is watching this [ __ ] over in
trouble that's funny
in case you guys don't know
i have two brothers and a sister
my brother
eric is four years younger than me
and there he is
john gore says librarian chicks
i am also into librarian chicks
i like that i like that smart thing with
the glasses
they can whip off the
whip off the rubber band and like make
their hair fly around take the glasses
off look i'm hot now oh
i never would have imagined
but yeah
oh my god
holy [ __ ] now i'm like all
self-conscious
look at you it's your hair
seriously yeah i'm just having fun you
really should like brush that though
i noticed because i had to buy well i
was wearing that one for a while and
then i was like man this one's all
[ __ ] up because he never
cause he never brushes it so i bought
another one
because it's just all
holy crap christian girls they're freaks
yeah
um
did you ever have the thing
uh where
they're like well i'm i want to stay a
virgin so
go in the butt no it's like the loophole
that happens in greece i think a lot
yeah yeah
or you see the loophole
oh now everybody's like jumping in
grandpa says eric share some jenny's
stories from back in the day
yeah
seriously my my brother eric is awesome
actually both my brothers are awesome my
sister is also awesome all my
siblings are awesome
all my siblings are awesome
tom doesn't have any siblings no i'm not
only chat he doesn't know what that's
like
what oh it's a spider
get it look no
he's already sorry buddy
you're all right little dude do i see
that
he's right there he's right there
he's like oh [ __ ]
what have i done excuse me excuse me
he's going down
he's flying over there that's amy
okay and you're not gonna go dance in
tampa yeah that that's amy come on go
dance at tampa yeah get some video for
them
that's that's that's the [ __ ] biker
the biker bartender chick that [ __ ]
wants me to [ __ ] strip it or damn
do it no
no she saw you oh she got some big
titties too that girl loves you
she's like bring her over here
okay one day i'll go yeah it's just like
how long do i have to stay though
because i'm like how long do i well i
can spin
we need to go during the day when there
when there isn't a bunch of uh
other people in there
and i have [ __ ] run of the jukebox
well what day is good to go then
that's the place we're talking about
that's the oasis that's actually amy's
jeep
she's a jeep girl
look at this spider yeah what's up bud
he's like a special guest
that's all right i'm not gonna [ __ ] with
you
you're fine you're fine all right i like
spiders tom does not
[Laughter]
tammy says yep i see the spider okay
that's good then i'm not crazy yeah
there's a spider he's right here he's
very very small or he or she i don't
know i don't know but he's doing the
thing
john smith says the poophole loophole
that's what they call it what
you don't know about that yeah yeah the
food yeah i've heard the loophole
well you're technically still a virgin
at virgin i think oscar says you guys
are missing parents we got children we
we [ __ ] have they just have fur yeah
well not only that [ __ ] nick is my
son
aaliyah is kind of like my daughter
we like adopt wayward adopt these goth
[Laughter]
as well as like furry kitties yeah but
i told you guys about the whole dream
that i had about pookie right you're
good too about
going too i dreamed that she could talk
yeah which wasn't even well the funny
thing about the dream was that that
wasn't even the most amazing thing of
like oh my god pookie can talk i mean
she does talk but like not in english
yeah
but i was like amazed at the fact that
she said
daddy has a mustache
what the [ __ ] and i was like oh my god
she's so smart and it's like but you
don't have a mustache though that's
[ __ ] funny and i think even my dream
you didn't have a mustache so i'm like
what the [ __ ] am i even talking about
but i don't know it's like it's it's
[ __ ] weird
you know what she did earlier
she um i had the you know i bought the
new printer like i mentioned at the
beginning of the show
and so it came in this big box
and so i took all the [ __ ] out of the
box and then i put it in the living room
like by the garbage can
and pookie
comes in to get tom
and she's like yelling hey hey hey hey
hey and tom's like what what do you want
and she's like come on and so like he
follows
the pookie into the living room and she
stops by the printer box
and looks at it and then looks at him
hey
yeah
yeah i forgot about that what is this
why is this here that's not what it was
i'm showing you
she calls me into the room she calls me
what what do you show me and then she
goes look box
yeah
it's a box box and then she's doing
you know it's just anything cats do look
at the box
isn't it great there's this box that
wasn't here before yeah this is amazing
she likes new [ __ ]
i put my boots out there last night
oh look at him she saw the damn
shoestrings on him and just she fought
those
shoe strings for an hour she loves
thomas booth by the way
i'm like get it pokey get it pookie and
i go back to watching [ __ ] on the table
get it pokey get it
she's fight she fought those boots for
an hour
anything that's out of the ordinary
because we're all on
we're all on schedules you know i mean
we all kind of do routines yeah if you
got to break the routine and then she
[ __ ] goes abe [ __ ] yeah she is
different now
like i did laundry in the middle of the
night and poured it out on her
inside the man cave and she just thought
that [ __ ] was great because it was not
on the bed
she loves more laundry by the way yeah
during normal more laundry
she runs in and she's like pour it on me
yeah pour it on me
yeah sit there and then come in and i'll
have the hamper fill the hot steaming
[ __ ] clothes and pour it on her and
she's going
she loves her little head poops
i'll [ __ ] cover her head back up like
that and she's like
[Laughter]
yeah she loves being inside a pile of
clothes yeah she's weird like that but
yeah it's
she definitely i mean well that's kind
of how like i get up at well she jumped
up on my chest at
like six this morning yeah
because you were sleeping in your man
cave because you have a cold and you
were coughing all night
i fell asleep at 10
and i slept all the way through until 6
15.
which is a big deal because usually i
wake up at two and at four to go to the
bathroom but i didn't
i woke up at six and then i was kind of
like i kind of got back in bed but then
i was like man [ __ ] it it's it's
daylight i'm getting up
and at that point like pookie was still
in her
bowl and she was just kind of like what
you're up
well [ __ ] because usually as soon as i
get up and go in the bathroom she's like
oh it's breakfast time and she'll like
toddle over and like sit by the
plate where i put her food out
and then she'll just sit there very
patiently
where's my can where's my wet food you
know so she'll do that
but you know
you all right yeah
alcohol
alcohol yeah i'm fighting it
yeah okay so uh what else you guys want
to talk about we can do paranormal we
can do [ __ ] true crime anything about
older shows
uh we could talk about the scene
uh
we could we could talk dirty we'll talk
whatever you guys want to talk about
we'll talk about it it's open lines it's
open lines friday
i [ __ ] love open lines i do too this
is super fun yeah this is my favorite
yeah
because uh you guys keep us rolling and
uh you know a lot of you guys are
heading towards the weekend we got all
kind we got long trawl hook we got we
got long truckers
listening and everything they're wishing
that they were [ __ ] drinking with us
but you got to [ __ ] carry that big
rig across the [ __ ]
rolling road with the [ __ ] dotted
lines and getting that white line fever
i know how it is
just let's talk about grapes
that's old stand by trying to get tom to
talk about [ __ ] grits grit trees and
when grits are in season
okay
and how the cycle of grits actually
happens but we're not going to talk
about that the grit cycle yeah the grist
i will say though that i haven't made
grits in a while yeah you have to
progress
one you have made grids in a while it's
time for grits two speaking of breakfast
this is jumping off from that yeah
the movie we watched last night which
i'm not gonna reveal because that'll be
the movie that we're gonna talk about on
sunday
but there was a scene in that
where the mom was like making breakfast
for the family
and it looked like french toast yeah and
i thought to myself
god damn it's been a long time since i
had french toast maybe we should eat
french toast uh i gotta go to uh i gotta
go next door to a dollar general i'll
get a loaf of bread oh we don't have any
bread i got some but it's not quite
enough yeah all right all right so
john's asked me about the georgia guy
stones what do i think about that's a
good question
i remember back when i was a kid
when the georgia guidestones were made
and a lot of people were
kind of mystified by it
georgia guidestones
i think it was like five
um
big granite or marble slabs that had all
this [ __ ] um
globalist style writing on it about how
to keep the population down and
uh to a certain level and but it's my
understanding i didn't know anything
about it at the time
recently now that somebody blew those
things up
i found out more about it recently
it was
context is is not modern
when you read what was written on them
it's it looks kind of dated
um it was supposed to be
a monument
for a post-apocalyptic society after the
nuclear war
because they were they they they came up
during the cold war when people actually
thought a nuclear war could happen at
any minute well we kind of did think
that people thought that yeah but that
would never happen although at the time
me coming up in a military school i
understood about mutually assured
destruction i knew what the truth was
about nuclear weaponry
and kind of how in in some ways
ineffective they were which that's a
whole nother show a lot of what people
know about nuclear weaponry is uh
propaganda
uh they're made out to be a lot worse
than they really are
for our advantage and it had a lot to do
with us lying to the soviets because the
soviets couldn't afford the nuclear
research
so we magnified the [ __ ]
abilities of those things a lot because
we knew that the soviets would just copy
whatever we said
um
yeah they're dangerous you don't want to
use those but uh
they're not it's not yeah but they're
not as they're not as catastrophic as
people think
uh you could have a nuclear still
and
life would continue people would survive
it um
but it's best not to do that
um
now
what's written on them is kind of out of
date
somebody went and blew them up as a
protest against globalism
as if it had something to do with the
with the wwef for the world economic
forum
which is a very different more modern
version of globalism and what they're
trying to do which is a very corrupt
form of globalism
it doesn't have anything to do with
democracy or world peace or anything
like that it's not what the uf the wef
and the un are about
the w w-e-f and the u-n are about making
money
it's a corrupt organization
over the years i picked up [ __ ]
especially during the first gulf war
when i joined
was fascinated with as saddam was
and later on
a us army
guard and he was a spec four
was one of saddam hussein's
jailers
and he had a long conversation with
saddam and he wrote a book about it
which i read
and saddam said some [ __ ] to him
that at the time i didn't believe
but now it it's all true
and it had to do with the corruption
inside the united states and the u.n
of how that they were using
a false premise of trying to make global
peace through the un charter but in fact
what they were doing is that they were
waging war and beating up on small
countries
to make profit not for the united states
but for the oligarchs that controlled
the united states
it had nothing to do with fairness it
had nothing to do with international law
about profit
profit and power
and if you look at world history with
the humans it always gets down to that
really
so the w
the w e f or the world economic forum is
very much the same thing what they say
is all lies what it's really about is
power and money
they blew up the goal the the uh
somebody
a couple
i guess it's about a week or so back
blew up the georgia guidestones
in
um
protest of what's happening with the w
the w e f and everything that's
happening right now
which
uh i don't support violence i can't
support violence they'll [ __ ] hate
the channel i understand why they did it
i think it was symbolic
more than anything else because the
people that built those guide stones
really have nothing to do with the
modern forms of globalism
all right it was a misunderstanding
but
history is mostly symbolism and uh what
do you call it
performance art
you know
they didn't like what that thing said
they didn't like what it [ __ ] stands
for
they blew it up
because slowly over time
no form of
globalism would ever be democratic that
would not be possible it would be
totalitarian
which
i don't support totalitarianism so
understand why things happened that's
all i'm going to say about that
but as i said it seems kind of pointless
to blow up something like that
yeah but
i mean it got pressed it got so i guess
it wasn't completely symbolism
yeah i get that it's symbolism
uh the thing is though is that um
the globalism that the makers of the
guidestones are talking about is a very
archaic form of globalism
that is not what we're dealing with now
okay
that was uh
they were talking about a
post-apocalyptic globalism that has not
yet happened
but i can understand why they attacked
the ideas because
if you actually analyze what's written
on the guide stones what it boils down
to is eugenics
okay that has a lot to do with it
selective breeding of human beings
killing off the weak and the
unacceptable
population control and that can only be
done through totalitarianism which is
basically the
the dream of the german national
socialists and the communists making
nazi superman or or the communist
perfect man okay
and all that [ __ ] is bad
governments can't be trusted with that
kind of power because
they're corrupt
the more powerful the government is the
more corrupt it's going to get
uh you cannot separate mankind from
corruption
what's better is decentralization and
freedom and liberty
and good morals
and local governments
and
people having freedom of choice
and if one area wants one thing let them
do that if another area wants another
one let them do that don't try to get
everybody on a single page
of music because you'll just [ __ ]
have to kill a bunch of people because
no one will agree with you
everybody disagrees
uh
i'm a live and let live kind of person
and i'm not big into normal [ __ ]
versions of the [ __ ] what they're
saying about paradigms between left and
right i think those are fake dichotomies
that came from
basically
german
social studies from the [ __ ] 20s and
the 30s that ended up being the
frankfurt school of thought which is all
false it's all
on the line of [ __ ]
it's marxism
which is illegitimate it is exactly the
same as
scientology
scientology is just a fake version of
what the marxists were doing
uh it saw pseudoscience with the marxist
you can't trust that let people be
people
that people work things out at a local
level let people be different
um
don't try to let him don't try to force
everyone to agree
that will only lead to suffering
totalitarianism
concentration camps and mass murder
and history will i'm not lying history
will demonstrate this over and over and
over again
control freaks try to run [ __ ]
when they fail to run [ __ ] they murder
people to make what they want happen
even though these are just other
mortal men
who are stupid and prejudiced
and [ __ ] have [ __ ] bad ideas okay
no one can be trusted with that amount
of power
we were built to be tribal
let that happen
protect people from
crime
but let local communities figure that
out
thank you very much mango what do you
say
great review of the new york ripper
thank you very much yeah and yes you
cannot get it uncut in the uk till this
day that's what i thought and honestly
it's not
that bad i mean compared to some [ __ ]
that i've seen recently
it's really not that bad you have to get
it imported from the us or belgium there
are also different cuts of it which
change the end of the film
yeah i mean
new york ripper like i've seen worse
but
it is a very
misanthropic
film i love lucio folgi i do
i love all of his
i love zombie i love the beyond honestly
if you haven't seen the psychic or
murder to the tune of seven black notes
i think it was called um that's probably
my favorite bulging movie which is crazy
but
new york ripper a lot of people like
complain about that because it's kind of
like misogynistic but
i don't know a lot of jealous were i i
didn't really have a problem with it and
honestly
it's not my favorite folgi film but i
like it a lot
i it amazes me that you can't get the
uncut version
in the
uk today because
you know
that's crazy
crazy
camp guy says my favorite name for a
male grandkid would be donna short for
adonis
and a neighbor named donis i didn't know
his real name wasn't jordan
okay that's cool that's cool
uh let's see
john gore says is that grotesque
rotescu grotescu
it's probably the most intense film i've
seen it's well done though
where is that from like what year was it
where did it come from because i don't
think i've seen that
murder hornets says video nasties i did
a show about video nasties a long time
ago
because
i was in the uk for a while and i was
like fascinated by the whole video
nasties phenomenon
um
it's just kind of like the whole
and if you haven't seen the
very recent movie sensor i think it came
out in 2020 or 2021
um it's about somebody that works in the
british board of film classification
like the censors
and
i don't know it seems to me like it was
very very arbitrary like you were just
like a group of people watching a movie
and it's like what offended you
like
why did you feel like this needed to be
cut out and that not
so
i don't really know like i said new york
ripper
um
it's a
misanthropic film for sure
but
i've seen like way way worse so i don't
really understand like why it would be
still banned to this day i really don't
understand like why it would still be
cut
but because there's really nothing in
there that's any worse than anything
that i've seen in the last
10 20 years in movies but for real
so i don't know but i i don't know i'm
i've always been kind of like interested
in
this is the reason i'm not really into
like film censorship if if it's a fake
movie
you're having like a group of people
watch a movie
and say well i don't like this or i
don't like that or whatever and like
they're gonna cut that out and it just
kind of seems like i don't know it's
just very arbitrary it's very arbitrary
and
new york ripper i think like fell into
that
category like i said it's not my
favorite folgi movie i liked his more
supernatural stuff or is more kind of
like
you know the psychic is probably my
favorite to be i know that's weird but
that's probably my favorite
but neurographer is really good and i
don't really know why they cut it
it's not that bad
compared to some [ __ ] i've seen recently
it's really not that bad
um
mango says yeah that
that era sucked
i don't know what are you stopping wait
whatever video nasties okay yeah
i mean
like i said it's just kind of like look
if you make a movie as long as you're
not putting
real [ __ ] in it look look i get
i get the [ __ ] about like rigaro diodato
and you know cannibal holocaust and like
the real animal deaths
i get that yeah i don't watch that [ __ ]
i don't really want to watch a real
animal being killed in real time
that's not cool
all right i get it i've watched it get
that [ __ ] sharp stick through that
[ __ ] character that [ __ ] what is
it what's that thing called a watamundi
a koat of monday a and i was like no
turn that [ __ ] off [ __ ] yeah i want to
see it i get that yeah i mean i i
understand violence
but i can only en enjoy it against
somebody that i [ __ ] hate and you
better done something really [ __ ]
wrong before i [ __ ] really hate you
i'm i'm [ __ ] consider myself to be a
forgiving person
you got to be really bad for me to
[ __ ] stick a sharp stick through you
you know whatever
and why would you do that to a [ __ ]
little innocent little animal that's why
he didn't do anything yeah he didn't do
anything no i couldn't do it so
i've watched it
i don't love it yeah and especially when
they kill that turtle
i heard that was a bad one they cut that
turtle apart right this flap yeah yeah
they just pulled it right out of the
water and cut its head off and like
pulled it ew yeah
kill all the people you want leave the
[ __ ] animals alone no don't don't no
no no none of that well not really yeah
i'm just saying like in a movie you're
right you can kill all the people you
want fake in a movie don't do a snuff
movie but don't kill animals for real
god damn italy but yeah so it was that
um mango said sensor was an interesting
movie but not that great my view that's
it yeah that's cool i loved that movie
though i really really liked sensor a
lot
uh my brother patriots revenge says
didn't the damned play a song called
video nasties on the young ones many
moons ago yes they did yes they did
there was a uh young ones episode called
nasty
and
the guys
if you haven't seen the young ones
please watch it it was like a um
would you call it a sitcom i guess you'd
call it a sitcom like from the early 80s
from like the uk
and they would always have bands on the
show and it was like
it was live but they had the damned on
one and it was called nasty
and the guys in the um
in the house
they
rented like a like a horror movie or a
snuff movie or something like that
and then there was like a vampire
like a real vampire that was involved
and the damned were there and they did a
song called nasty and i used to have
that song on my phone i don't think i
have it anymore but yeah it's like it's
it's really fun
that's probably that one and like the
university challenge episode were
probably my favorite ones seriously
but
i don't know like what was i talking
about okay
mango says i worked in the film industry
for a while and the classification board
could be bought or paid off for a lure
certificate
yeah
and murder hornet says bbc news got in
trouble for showing clips of saddam's
hanging yeah yeah remember when that
happened yeah i mean
saddam was not a
a good guy but he was right about a lot
of things that he said about the united
states and how it worked another one
that they [ __ ] killed unjustly was
gaddafi
gaddafi went along with everything that
the west wanted including giving up his
nuclear weapons and he was a good ally
to us
and because he got in front of the un
saying that the u.n thought was
violating their charter and waging more
war than preventing it
and then he said we need to get on a new
currency that was not the us [ __ ]
petro dollar
they killed him 16 months later for that
he said that the [ __ ] petrol dollar
was keeping africa and the rest of the
world poor on purpose
uh and [ __ ] go back and look at
[ __ ] gaddafi's he's
they were saying well it's a crazy
rambling rant is how they
portray it go look at it with subtitles
he might have been high
but he wasn't stupid
he was absolutely right
and they killed him
for going against the grain i i don't
agree with that
i don't agree with that he didn't do
anything wrong and then they [ __ ]
[ __ ]
his country up what was this country not
chad it was uh
i forgot the name of the country that he
came from and then that country
collapsed and they had next thing you
know they're having slave markets and
just no the [ __ ] the u.n did [ __ ]
they did gaddafi dirty
you know it was i don't agree with that
not at all because he was he was
actually playing by the rules but tried
to free himself
history what history will tell
mango said i would be very happy to burn
cannibal holocaust it's a vile movie
however it is very influential one yeah
i like i wouldn't do that because like i
said it's a piece of art
um so
i don't really agree with
censoring it but
and i've watched it in its uncut form
um if you're an animal lover i don't
suggest it that's right libya libya okay
yeah libya was the country yeah they
[ __ ] libya up for no good reason go
back and look at his [ __ ] speech to
the u.n with subtitles
everything he said was true
everything
he was right
i thought he was crazy at the time but
no it was true
i just wasn't ready to hear it
i didn't
i believed back then
okay
but yeah i mean i would defend the movie
as a piece of art but
i would rather all the animal cruelty
wasn't in there like if you're gonna do
it as found footage and you're going to
make it as realistic as possible which
they did
um
you know that's fine that was like an
early
you know incidence of found footage but
they really didn't need to kill actual
animals like to do it and
you know i'm kind of like not into that
so you know
uh
yeah i mean so i wouldn't burn it but
i'm not going to watch it again probably
now somebody named auntie hula payne and
says talk about jennifer farragut the
woman who was found dead of a gunshot
wound
in a norwegian luxury hotel in 1985. oh
i kind of remember that game wait a
minute isn't that honestly we should
probably do a whole show about that
that's not the one i suspected to be in
the east german
spy we're not talking about is all women
no it was a long time okay yeah
this was like yes well no that was 70s
80s
when was that is all women i think was
80s 40s or 80s no 50s it was a long time
ago eight i think he was like
he's the one with the browning high
power
the cute girl the black bob
the shoes
found dead she shot herself
no that's the case she's talking about
is doll woman was
a long time ago okay
so i think you're thinking of the one
that she's talking about okay
but maybe we should maybe we should that
would probably be a good one to have out
because i kind of feel like we did a
show about
is doll woman and somerton man
and i think that was like an espionage
yeah type of show
there was a lot of stuff with the uh
east germans east germans had a lot of
intelligence
agents that were sex operatives
they would show up dead every now and
then
under weird circumstances
it was hard to track the girl down where
she came from
and
typically what they would do is they get
them out of orphanages or prisons
turn them into a sex operative and send
them into the west
to become a fake hooker slash girlfriend
to somebody
they'd be able to report back
but you know
that's the theory but that's usually
what happens in intelligence work
joe gore said i like deodo's first
cannibal movie simply called cannibal
yeah i mean
he seems like an alright dude like i've
seen
interviews with him and he seems like
you know he doesn't seem like a dick or
anything but
man i don't really know like why he
wanted like the very similitude i guess
hey let's kill like real animals
so now it's like it's kind of like
seeing cannibal holocaust
every time i watch an italian movie from
like the early 70s
and i see an animal in the movie like a
cat or something i'm like oh my god are
they gonna kill this animal yeah because
they clearly did not give a [ __ ] they
clearly didn't give a [ __ ]
but
you know
there's that
um
[Music]
blair witch and found footage movie
stole from it they did they did
so i'll give it
that much cannibal holocaust
was probably
probably the first found footage movie
that was presented as such
so i kind of feel like blair witch gets
all the credit but
cannibal holocaust
was
way
way earlier
and they had some real [ __ ] in there
so much so that they got like brought
into court
didn't we do a show about that did we do
a show about cannibal holocaust yeah
they brought them into court because
they thought that
the people in the theater like the thing
really got killed they didn't
but the animals did
okay so we're approaching uh hour two
uh what do you wanna do you wanna um
i would like another drink actually okay
i would like it see what they want to
talk about adjusting trying to get a
subject adjust your wig
yeah i was watching um
yeah i was watching another italian
movie earlier because
i'm still doing uh geolo july
on flickers of fear
and today i was watching
uh death walks on high heels
and
i just had like a reaction like as soon
as some character like had a cat
in the in the film i was just kind of
like oh my god i think bad's gonna have
a cat nothing happened nothing bad
happened to cat though but because there
was like a scene where somebody had the
cat and i was just kind of like
i was freaking out because like it's
italy you never know you never know what
they're gonna do
they might kill the cat and like [ __ ]
vivisect it i don't know
they would do that it was 1971.
john gore said i think the cannibal
cycle sprang into this african
documentaries as italians yeah like
mondo connie and stuff like that
i kind of feel like ever did everybody
like rent those back in the day um mondo
connie was like the big one
right you never heard of mondo connie no
holy [ __ ] where have you been
what are you talking about everybody
who's renting that in the 80s never
heard of it it's a document it's kind of
like faces of death but it was italian
oh i've never seen it um
it translates
to uh dog world
basically so it was just kind of like
they were showing you like a bunch of
clips of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
back in the 80s everybody rented that
back in the old days i rented it
everybody read it
uh dan michael says bad titles bad sign
cannibal holocaust is not appealing to
me i mean
i'm not gonna like recommend that people
watch it like it's influential
um
especially if you're into found footage
about cannibal holocaust don't watch
that [ __ ] i'm just saying if you're into
found footage
uh that's kind of like the og
but
if you really don't want to watch like
real animals being killed no [ __ ] that
[ __ ] yeah then don't watch it because
it's yeah i mean and
it'll just need what was that holy [ __ ]
it'll just needlessly piss you off
yeah because they're they're they're
killing animals for no good reason and i
mean they're not even animals the people
that die in it yeah i mean they didn't
really die so it's fine it's like
whatever i mean it is realistic
but you know they're not animals but the
animals that get killed in it yeah
are real animals that get killed in it
so if you're not down with that i would
not suggest that you watch it
yeah it's not a fun time yeah they're
not even animals that you can eat
and they're not slaughtering them
[ __ ] painlessly like you would yeah i
mean they're [ __ ] they're torturing
them so [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah it kind of makes me mad yeah like i
understand the importance
in film history
but
it still kind of like makes me mad
i don't really like like i said if
you're killing fake people
do that all day long i don't care don't
kill any real animals though
don't like it
um sebastian says how about the dario
argento films suspiria was okay suspiria
is actually one of my favorite
films uh from the 1970s easily
very very stylish i really really like
dario argento um
[Music]
he went downhill probably in the mid
1990s i kind of feel like the last movie
i like of his was
stendhal syndrome which was 1996.
um i haven't seen some of his newer ones
he has a newer one new one out
uh which i haven't seen yet
which i've heard is
okay
but
i don't know there are some ones in
there that like the card player which i
hated
and a few other ones that i wasn't super
into
wasn't super into
uh sebastian says phenomena was my
favorite that was actually a good one i
really liked phenomena i know a lot of
people don't um
[Music]
that was kind of like i don't think
you've seen that donald pleasance was in
it jennifer connolly was in it
and
it was a weird premise it was basically
like a girl that could
psychically control insects like there
was other [ __ ] going on too but it was a
giallo it's pretty much a geolo but with
supernatural aspects
and
i don't know i like that it's not my
favorite but
it's good it's good my favorite dario
argento probably suspiria although
i don't know deep red is up there
uh deep red is really good too
um
john gore says opera was his last great
good one yeah i agree i mean he did some
good ones in the 90s like i said i have
a soft spot for stonehall syndrome but
anybody that says opera is the last good
one i'm not going to argue with you
because opera was really good
that was 87. uh after that
not so much
has anybody seen
the new one
i've seen a couple reviews of it
on my horror channels but i haven't
watched them because it's like
well i want to watch the movie first and
like see how i feel about it but
what's it called dark shades or
black shades or something like that
victor says i never got around to
watching suspiria oh my god
okay
suspiria
well you kind of have to approach it
suspiria is very stylish it's very um
it's kind of like a a fairy tale
and you kind of have to approach it as
though it's like a fairy tale it's like
a witch story um
it's visually beautiful it's actually
suspiria is probably one of the most
beautiful
visually like movies that i've ever seen
my old house that i used to live in i
decorated entirely
in homage to zeus's barrier
that's how much i love that [ __ ] i love
that well i love the giallo aesthetic
but i love suspiria
in particular because i really really
like that that whole like uh visual
aesthetic they have going on in that
yeah right yeah
what's up pokey so seriously nobody's
seen the the new dario argento one i'm
dying i'm dying to know if it's any good
but
i stopped watching his stuff i watched
the card player when did the card player
came out sometime in like the [ __ ]
90s
and
it was
terrible and then i watched his
didn't he do a dracula
that was also terrible
and then i watched
mother of tears which was his
that was probably like earlier but that
was like his third in the
whole like um trilogy
spirit inferno
the three mothers trilogy
want to watch it again
but
i watched mother of tears in
probably the mid to late 90s
and i really did not like it
and i was kind of like this is nothing
like the other ones it's like not
thematically similar and it was just
like it made me mad
but
i'm willing to give it another go i've
seen it one time i've seen it one time
so one of these days i will watch it
again and see how it goes because
i really did like the whole
trilogy aesthetic about suspirian for
like the whole three mothers thing with
like the [ __ ]
you know
i liked that whole thing
so
i don't know i was just disappointed by
the third one but we'll see
we'll see
he's still around
have you seen his version of fan of the
album i have
uh
um it's not great it's not great
it's not great
um it's not as bad as
his
weird ass um
later stuff
it's not terrible but i didn't love it i
didn't love it it was just kind of like
i don't know man i just kind of feel
like
i wish he would go
i don't know i don't know what i wish
i just wish that he would just like stop
doing what he's doing
what are you talking about dario
i love dario i do
but i kind of feel like his best work
was pre-1990
after that
it was very hit or miss and i will go to
bat for some of his 90 stuff like
stenhall syndrome i think that was a
good movie
but
and even trauma was good i did a review
of that
but
and someone like he did um
masters of horror remember that series
he did one called jennifer that was good
that was good
so he still he still has it in him but
man
a lot of the stuff that he did
especially like a lot of the dialogues
that he did later i haven't seen giallo
the one that he did called giallo but
man i saw the card player
um sleepless was okay but the card
player i [ __ ] hated it was awful
but i haven't seen his new one so i
don't know what you're doing i don't
know
trying to get me to do something
to get me to interact huh
yeah she's like man come on here and do
something
yeah come late with her yeah look at
your look at your hair with my hair
[Laughter]
you know like get a brush no i'm just
[ __ ] got it on i just got the [ __ ]
hair on that's all you have to mean it's
a hair hat you can't just like put a wig
on and like i don't have a brush i don't
have a brush i got a brush over there
but it's got pookie air in it and i
gotta brush it in there
manga said i always thought it was a
lazy adaptation yeah i mean it wasn't
great
it wasn't awful
but
it could have been a lot better could
have been a lot better
remember we did that show about like the
real story behind phantom of the opera
i kind of feel like yeah yeah you
remember that yeah
i kind of feel like somebody needs to
make a movie out of that [ __ ]
yeah when did we get down we got down to
it that that probably didn't
happen because the locations didn't
really well i told you and you were very
disappointed yeah i was very just when
you found out that like the [ __ ]
underneath yeah it was another kind of
found footage type [ __ ] show where
it's built on something that maybe
happened but no couldn't have no i mean
there is a thing under there like that
but not like it was described
in the people knew how to lie back in
the 1800s
they could lie they still do but people
don't fall for it as much although
people still do fall for it nowadays but
back then everybody fell for it
oh yeah i suppose so
right
i guess
um yeah so
auntie
okay the jennifer farragut case was
featured in the second episode the
second volume of the rebooted unsolved
mysteries
in october 2020. that's right we
watched
remember we watched the uh unsolved
mysteries
the new one
yeah
they talked about the case
where that woman
what are you doing taking my shoe up
where that woman
looked like she shot herself in the head
but some people thought she'd been
murdered
and that she was a spy maybe
you remember that no
i remember not at all i don't remember
what you talked about i remember that
when's this
what year is this
[Laughter]
no it's kind of vague he's getting more
and more like an old person no i'm good
that's
what are you talking about wait what are
you talking about what what
i remember that okay
that might be a good whole show
i have no idea what you're talking about
just saying
yeah i know we were talking i know what
that's not what you talk about
what else is that
what else
back up say it again
do you remember the new unsolved
mysteries okay on netflix yeah let's go
step by step okay
there was a new unsolved mystery series
on netflix do you remember that
kind of yeah
yeah yeah
are you sure yeah okay
do you remember that we watched it yeah
because we did yeah do you remember to
watch it yeah okay
well there was an episode
about this woman
who
died in a hotel room okay
that everybody thought was a suicide
but some people are thinking that maybe
she's a spy and that maybe it was a
murder because like she put the gun to
her head like that
you know what i'm saying do you remember
that
there i remember like three or four of
them that were like that
okay what year is this
i mean
what country germany right
fairly recently germany
i don't know it was fairly recent okay
i'm just saying
remember what kind of gun it was
no why would i remember because i would
remember that
so you know that's the only thing you
would remember okay yeah like the most
insignificant detail that's the only
thing
that's the only thing you would remember
yeah
victor says people are dumb [ __ ] these
days too i know people are dumb [ __ ]
always
it's it's sad
it's sad
it makes me very angry and impatient but
you gotta deal with dumbbells all the
time gotta deal with dumb [ __ ] all the
time
you know
bigger question is
someone's getting loaded
yeah but i i backed off
i backed off
look at her face look at her face
i'm just laughing at you because you're
like
yeah that's right
that's right
you're being like what's up what's up
yeah i can't control her
what's everybody talking about
victor says tom 1995 oslo norway nine
millimeter browning pistol yeah yeah
okay i remember that it was the browning
p-35
yeah okay so he remembers that yeah
remember that one that's the other they
never didn't figure out what that girl
was who that girl was well yeah she's
talking about that's what we're talking
about she was i remember her shoes she
had the little [ __ ] high heel shoes a
little short haircut
she looked like somebody that would go
in an old [ __ ] club back in those
days
during the new wave era
she was some kind of sex operative
agent
and i remember that that pistol
was kind of like stood out in the time
europeans are freaked out about that
because well that's not a pistol for
self-defense that's a pistol for attack
because it's nine millimeter i'm like
what
what the [ __ ] you talking about
all pistols are for self-defense
if i can if you go to a [ __ ] gun
fight with a [ __ ] pistol you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you go to a gunfight with
a rifle all right [ __ ]
pistols are always last ditch weapons
so it's a weapon of defense
um
but that's just what they gave her
you know
she was some kind of sex operative
dan says dumb [ __ ] procreate more smart
people find less related yeah sad but
true
yeah sad but true
sebastian says jenny and tom the keep
yeah by michael mann yeah it's an
incomplete film but still worth a look
um i like the movie you know what's
crazy he's reading the book i am reading
the book yeah at this moment yeah and
actually the review of it will go up on
july
25th yeah
i actually want a blu-ray copy of that
if anybody man the book is really good
yeah if anybody wants a review of that
movie send us a blu-ray copy if it's if
it's available on blu-ray it may not be
and uh we'll review it i want to see
that one
the book is so good yeah
i'm just like i'm probably only like an
eighth of a way into it but man it's
good
basically a jewish monster story
uh
about kind of like a golem
basically basically it's about like a
golem and the nazis [ __ ] find a place
where they were keeping it
prisoner and they
inadvertently let it go
and it does all kinds of [ __ ]
you know
but it's a
i remember the movie it was good but i
haven't seen it in so long you know i
wanted more of a modern take on it
in the book there's so much i could buy
it but there's so much stuff competing
for time
uh we jenny and i always move to
whatever people send us
people send us something then that goes
to the top of the list
uh especially in recent times i even got
around to [ __ ] collateral we had
collateral in the back burner for
several years
and we eventually got around to that and
i think i got three versions of
collateral
so many people like recommended
it and stuff yeah
right
but and collateral turned out to be a
[ __ ] badass flick i liked it so i see
why they wanted wanted me to well it was
one of those things where it's like we
started watching it and i was just kind
of like this sucks and then like
come on and then like
and then once you get past that like
first yeah yeah
oh my god this is awesome once tom
cruise is in it he's in the backseat of
that [ __ ] taxi and he starts talking
oh okay this is the setup now
but they have to [ __ ] get this uh
chick
her story in into it early on because
they're gonna they're gonna do a call
back to her later uh
and if you don't know that if you're
watching the movie the first time you're
like this is kind of [ __ ] slow
but no once tom gets in there and then
you realize that he's a [ __ ] assassin
it's tom cruise playing a villain
and tom is a lot like arnold
schwarzenegger tom plays a better
villain than he does the [ __ ] hero
but he doesn't want to play he doesn't
want to play him right yeah even though
that's obviously his calling yeah tom
does a much better villain
uh he makes a better [ __ ] bad guy
vampire uh he makes a better [ __ ] i
told tom today like at lunch i was like
you really need to watch tropic thunder
yeah i got to see that one yeah you
really should watch traffic thunder and
it's the same with arnold
arnold is [ __ ]
better as a villain although he was
great and predator one
he's better in terminator one when he's
a villain
yeah not so much terminator two this is
an okay movie good movie some people say
it's the best action movie uh nah
i did at the time but re-watching it i'm
like uh
it's not as good as i no terminator
one's a lot better terminator one's a
lot better
and uh
and he did some good [ __ ] [ __ ]
recently
arnold when he wasn't in his [ __ ]
i will only play heroes well yeah when
when he did after he
yeah after he kind of like relaxed up
shed that stuff and like played like a
normal person yeah he was better he can
actually act
yeah he was real good in maggie as the
[ __ ] in a zombie apocalypse which was
like a non-zombie zombie flick that was
kind of weird and then he did [ __ ] uh
i got one of his movies on blu-rays
about where he played an actual
character who was [ __ ]
trying to go after vengeance for guys
that what was it called about the plane
crash
oh yeah remember that what the [ __ ] was
that that was a [ __ ] weird flick he
played a psycho yeah that was all right
he played a psycho in it yeah he's very
believable as his [ __ ] psycho that's
what i'm saying yeah i mean people like
that people like tom cruise
they play better villains yeah but it's
like they don't want to because it's
like they have some weird thing where
it's like no i have to be portrayed as a
good guy i was like but you're not the
good guy well that'll kill you you're a
dick it'll kill your career if you go
that way i know i get it
but mango said maggie is great yeah
maggie is really yeah both of those guys
are better villains or neutral
oh kind of neutral dudes
uh
uh
i love thomas the villain tom cruise is
a villain good
same thing with [ __ ] arnold
his arnold's best movie
is predator one
it's just it's just a [ __ ] badass
flick
but his best work
most impressive work is [ __ ]
terminator one
conan one's good though too come on but
in terminator one he just plays a
[ __ ] emotionless evil robot and it's
just yeah that's that's arnold does come
out that's kind of his
emotionless evil [ __ ] robot basically
and he's
very impressive i mean i kind of feel
like as an actor
you have to kind of know what your
expertise
is
what are you good at yeah and i kind of
feel like arnold schwarzenegger tom
cruise people like that they're good at
being [ __ ] yeah they're good at
being [ __ ] i mean it's like that's
i'm not like [ __ ] on the people no
i'm not [ __ ] on them as people
i thought tom did a great [ __ ] lestat
because lestat is a [ __ ] prick he's
kind of an absolute [ __ ] prick and
[ __ ] and and
yeah okay so whenever tom cruise has to
play kind of an [ __ ] yeah he excels
yeah
but he has to play a good guy i don't
buy it
i don't buy it
well he's always playing the same guy
that's what i'm saying he's a good guy
and
i don't
that's the thing i don't buy him as a
good guy because he always comes across
as very
arrogant very condescending very smug
and it's like those are not um
qualities that i associate with a good
guy yeah so
every time i see him playing a good guy
i'm like ugh
i think you're saying that terminator 2
is definitely the best
terminator movie you know what i thought
that too until i re-watched it until i
re-watched it and i didn't like it as
much but i don't think it was arnold
schwarzenegger's fault i think it was
edward furlong his fault yeah that kid's
very annoying [ __ ] that kid yeah oh my
god and and
the story is kind of
weird
and there's a leather daddy kind of
[ __ ] vibe to it where you got eddie
furlong on the back of that damn harley
with arnold in front just the way
they're dressed that's [ __ ] leather
daddy [ __ ] you know i mean it's just
that movie's
too complicated
what made terminator great is that it
was simple like jaws
it's almost like a horror movie
well it is i would argue that it is yeah
and there really shouldn't have been any
kind of
exposition or explanations
for
um you know uh what do you call it the
dab
cybernet and all that
what do they call it no cyber nothing
called cybernetic cyber dying skynet
skynet cyberdyne there shouldn't have
been any kind of [ __ ] explanations
for that it should have just been t1 and
that's it that's it you don't need to
know anymore because the more they told
you
the weaker that story got
and then when you got
when you got skynet talking and having a
human [ __ ] voice and
face
no
you now have just [ __ ]
de-empowered skynet i'm telling you man
skynet was a comp should have been a
computer
insect-like intelligence that would
never deign to talk to you you know
shouldn't have been anything that you
could talk to it's just a bunch of code
you know
that's what made it
over explanation yeah i don't know he is
the [ __ ] killer of horror man
horror is like mystery
i consider anything after [ __ ]
terminator 1 really to just be fan
fiction terminator 2 is is
pretty good but it has problems
i'll say yeah okay
that's that's canon
but the rest of it's fan fiction if you
ask me they they [ __ ] it up picture
says top gun maverick was [ __ ] great
yeah everybody says that we still
haven't seen it we'll never be able to
see it probably we'll probably have to
get that [ __ ] on [ __ ] blu-ray oh we
could go to the movies
we never get around to it
i know yeah
we could go tomorrow
yeah although there's
so much [ __ ] we gotta do tomorrow i
still wanna
i still want to say no but also yeah
there's like so many movies
so many movies
uh grumpter says t2 is a father-son road
movie
a lot of the road and road to perdition
yeah it is kind of like that i get it
like that should not be that not in the
terminator series you're dealing with
jaws
basically
it's it's a horror movie there shouldn't
be any more than that i thought it
de-empowered or demystified
the terminator franchise and and
terminator 2
set that that franchise along a bad path
because it just got worse
well
we've talked about this earlier because
i kind of feel like a lot of horror
sequels
um
you know by design or you know by
necessity i guess
they're kind of like gonna have to over
explain stuff
because
we did this one movie
and
we didn't expect it to be successful but
it was successful
so the producers asked to please make
another one so we made another one so we
have to like explain all the
you know for example like the backstory
of
the killer yeah
and
that kills your [ __ ] horror works better
the less it's explained well to an
extent you can't explain nothing because
everybody's like what the [ __ ] is going
on
but
to a degree i think that
you really can't overexplain your
villain
that's one thing you can't explain like
over explain the situation it makes it
less scary yeah
they brought they brought arnold back
and then they turned him into a father
figure
determined it's just
i just thought it was a bad that
well he was so scary in the first one
i mean because he was the villain and it
was so scary and it's like bringing it
back in the second one where he was like
more family friendly yeah
i didn't love it it's like
you know it's a good movie
just as a movie
it's a great action movie yeah it is i'm
not saying that
t1 is a horror movie oh
a lot different
what i'm saying and i'm like a horror
person right so it's just kind of like
if you're doing a horror movie
yeah you don't want to over explain that
[ __ ] [ __ ] like explain a little bit
but
just
enough don't give them your whole
backstory don't give them like oh i had
a bad childhood or like nobody wants to
hear that [ __ ] nobody wants to hear that
[ __ ]
just [ __ ] it's much scarier if you
don't know yeah
a lot of stuff
well they you gotta you gotta give it to
them that they knew how to capitalize on
t1 though when they came out with t2 it
probably made more money
but it's still a good movie i'm not
going to argue that it's not it's still
a good movie it's just i think i think
it it it parted ways from the terminator
franchise
and it was a good movie but it sent it
down
a bad path
a
a path of over explaining
over humanizing
[ __ ] uh the arnold
terminator character it shouldn't have
been like that
it should have been [ __ ] alien and
cold
and
and horror through the whole thing yeah
like don't demystify right like you can
demystify in like
little pieces but don't
don't do like [ __ ] rob zombie did
with
uh you know
michael myers in the halloween remake
don't explain the bitch's whole
backstory and say oh let's feel bad for
this abused child like don't do that
don't do that
that like undercuts every single
mango says it right you enjoyed t2 for
the action yeah pretty much you enjoyed
t1 for the story
yeah
and that's a simple story yeah i mean
that's kind of the reason that out of
all the franchises
um
i enjoy teach you i enjoy aliens
yeah um but of all the big franchises i
i was like the first ones i like the
first halloween i like the first alien
because that's more like a
horror movie yeah all of that kind of
stuff because nothing's explained right
it's scarier
it's scarier if [ __ ] sounds explained
i'm about you but i'm getting tired
sebastian says halloween three as a
standalone movie yeah
i mean we're big fans of halloween yeah
i like halloween three i like halloween
three as well it's almost kind of like a
cronenberg movie i just liked it it's a
good movie and i saw that one not
knowing anything about halloween one or
two i didn't know anything about it i
just saw three first and [ __ ] loved
it
you know i
i had not been tainted
well i mean carpenter's whole vision and
i'm not [ __ ] up because it's like a
good idea he was like look i made a
halloween movie it was a slasher movie
he's like i want to do a movie every
year
that's based around halloween but that's
different he wanted to do like
essentially like an anthology
but spread out over
like we'll make a movie every year but
it's like an anthology
which is a great idea but
producers not so much
weren't really into it so halloween two
um is essentially like
the same thing as halloween but you know
the same night and it's like in
continuation but winning at halloween
three
he's like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna like do
a completely different story no michael
myers no nothing yeah
stonehenge
yeah
and if you like look at like i can get
why people didn't like it at the time
but i don't know i kind of feel like a
lot of people like it nowadays because
they're not seeing it in the same
context they were homage in it in the in
the last [ __ ] halloween we saw in the
theater sure yeah the masks and
everything
that's right yeah remember yeah i know
mango says halloween three is great i
honestly i love halloween three yeah but
it's its own thing it's its own thing
uh granthar says top gun maverick
just surpassed avatar in the billion
dollar club
but three avatars are in the hopper
i mean did anyone ask for that though
because i don't even really remember the
first avatar
i saw it
not in the theater i didn't like avatar
well i was you know i was i wasn't i
didn't like it or dislike it yeah it
wasn't really impressive it was just
kind of like there
yeah somebody
i don't know i just watched it and it
was just like is black phone good think
of buying it tonight
never heard of it
no it's the ones in the theater ethan
hawk isn't it
it's a new blum house
i've told you about it several times
um but yeah i've been wanting to watch
it
i still haven't watched it yet so i
don't know if it's good or not but a lot
of people i don't know i've been seeing
like mixed reviews most people say it's
good
we haven't been in a theater in like
forever
i wanted to go to the theater and see it
several black phone man nope i would say
there's like a bunch of movies i want to
say yeah we had one no was nobody good
i don't know it's it just came out it
just came out it's at the theater
it's at the theater now
avatar was dances with wolves with blue
people yeah says my brother yeah i saw
right through the [ __ ] blue people at
an angle i was like oh man they're weird
you know what's weird about
about they should have been they're not
alien looking enough they're just blue
people
the weird thing the thing that kills me
on avatar
is that this movie comes out it made
what like 40 bajillion dollars it made a
lot of money
and it was just kind of like
but
five or ten years later nobody talked
about that [ __ ] no it was like not
memorable
it was kind of like it was like i saw it
like somebody like i used to work with a
guy who pirated like a whole bunch of
movies so he would just be like hey
wanna watch this i'm like yeah why not
so i watch it it's free
and i'm just like yeah okay and it was
just kind of like
i don't have to pay for it so i watched
avatar and i was just kind of like
yeah okay cool
it really didn't
sexy blue people it made they may have
well been elves it's the same thing
they're they're so close to here it's a
good move this is another version of it
but it's not really that
[ __ ] legit it wasn't really
i don't know yeah it didn't have that
thing that made me want to like
you know yeah i don't know but the thing
about it is that i i don't know i have
very idiosyncr syncretic taste i guess
i see movies that are like that nobody
gives a [ __ ] about i'm like oh my god
that's the best movie ever yeah and then
like that happened
um camp guy said i remember we had a
family movie day at christmas
we took my 88 year old mother to see
avatar she was borderline catatonic yeah
was able to
it was able to watch the theater that's
funny
i mean they took an 88 year old to see
[ __ ] avatar what'd she think of it
afterwards she said oh it was great that
she fell asleep john gore said it was no
matrix and to be honest with you even
the matrix matrix wasn't matrix
a matrix wasn't all that
is this a hot take yeah the first one
was okay they got worse as they went
yeah i mean i don't i saw the first
matrix and i was just kind of like yeah
yeah
seen it
i don't know i liked blade a lot better
than matrix that was around the same
time the matrix was good but it's like i
don't know it it didn't really like make
that much of an impression the way that
it made
i don't know maybe
it might be because we've been we've
been in like the goth scene and all that
kind of [ __ ] for like a long time so
like matrix [ __ ] that was like old hat
so by the time that came out i'm like
yeah cool seen it
yeah i wasn't really like that like yeah
this is cool but i hadn't
right i don't know it wasn't really that
original
like it was cool but it wasn't that
original
it wasn't original so i don't know maybe
it was that
i don't know what it was
victor said when i worked in the oil
field
i printed uh i pirated pacific rim
so i could watch it at work and it was
in russian still watch it though i mean
pacific rim is well it's pretty good
giant robots it's pretty good yeah
um
yeah but he's like
hugo says i like dark city better than
matrix um i'm gonna agree with you on
that
i don't think you've seen dark city have
you i've seen bits and pieces of it i
think
um it was really yeah
it kind of reminded me of brazil in a
certain way i'm going to agree with you
on that
movie brazil yeah i haven't seen that in
a long time i actually like dark city
better than the matrix also so you're
not alone
i will show you dark dark city one of
these days yeah you would probably
really be into that
first matrix came out when i was in high
school
it was great
uh the rest sucked couldn't even finish
the last one
uh mako says the matrix movies are very
overrated
first one gets better after second
viewing and it should have ended there
yeah
i bought them all on blu-ray in a big
set for like 10 bucks used online
and i watched i think two or three of
them and i was just like i lost interest
they were movies of their places and
their times you know what i mean
they're not impressive by today's
standards
good special effects it did it did yeah
but that was but by the time the first
matrix came out
like when all those like ideas were just
i was like
yeah
i don't know like we've already done
that we've already been there and it was
just kind of like it was futuristic in
its day though it was like i get that
yeah i don't know i get that maybe that
was like the first mainstream
acceptance of it but i was just kind of
like yeah
okay
it really didn't seem that like [ __ ]
out there to me and i was just kind of
like okay cool
whatever i didn't really i wasn't really
that into it
and then
i didn't even bother like with the
sequels to be honest
i mean the first one's good
the first one's good but
um
i will
concede
that probably
dark city is better
i do like dark city better
um
[Music]
hugo says brazil is a great flick it is
terry gilliam yeah
cherry kill him he's the [ __ ] man
but blade is better yeah i agree with
that also
canvas says movies i watch with my young
son
the matrix one taxi driver
vanilla sky fight club being john
malkovich
he was nice to pause the video games and
watch old movies with me now
see this is what i
this is what's interesting to me
how did
the kids
react to something like for example
being john malkovich which is a great
[ __ ] movie i love that movie
how did they react
to that
i have no context
uh from which to
get to that
camp guy says the grifters young and
that benning topless scenes awesome
have to agree dark city is far better i
mean i have to show like tom dark city
some because
i mean i don't know like dark city
it
it was their first
one and
i don't know it's just a better film the
matrix is good
but i kind of feel like dark city is
like a better film
i don't know
camp guy said he didn't say much about
it he was probably 10 years old as well
okay
well i don't know i'm always kind of
like interested how
people that didn't grow up with it
react to
stuff that they didn't grow up with you
know
tom get back in here yeah yeah cookie
was up there in that [ __ ] bowl trying
to bite me
what's up because i had to pee okay so
you got a shop
all right let's see what everybody's
doing
okay
what's up my blade runner either someone
brazil is a great flick yeah brazil's a
great flick it was weird because it
wasn't he didn't know if it was an
action flick or if it was a uh
you know some kind of [ __ ] sci-fi or
it was just a weird movie about
totalitarianism and
i don't know if i'll call it out there
bureaucracy
more about bureaucracy
you had a
bunch of different characters and
it didn't have anything to do with
brazil
but uh what was his name again robert de
niro was in it he played a terrorist
that would come into your window and fix
your plumbing
uh he would fix your plumbing even
though the paperwork said that you
couldn't that
that you couldn't fix it you know it's
kind of [ __ ] pretty cool
a lot of [ __ ] happened in it
dudes mom dude worked in a damn bureau
that just [ __ ] erased history sounds
real familiar doesn't it but he's racing
history and his mom was [ __ ] spending
all her time getting down plastic
surgery
going out with dudes half her age
just a trippy flick
yeah it was a guy from monty python that
did it
danny says that the matrix games are
actually better than the movies i never
played them
there was a game i used to play that
kind of reminded me something out of the
out of the matrix it was called
bloodrayne
and i think i played a couple of like
blood raid 1 and 2
for the old
xbox you could slow time down you would
play this vampire chick named rayne
it's pretty good i think you were
fighting nazis or something
and it's been a long time since i played
it she could do all these [ __ ]
backflips and
all these uh kicks and acrobatics and
she'd do it in slow motion he had guns
he also had i think [ __ ]
chains that would fly out and go into
guys they had like a needle on there you
can drain your blood
all kinds of weird stuff he's draining
blood yeah
oh
man can't guys usually watch shining the
cape fear
and more both my kids one
one but
i don't really tell him well he's
talking about like uh watching movies as
kids because i was asking about that oh
okay i don't really know how
people that are kids nowadays that don't
have the cultural context how they would
react to
step back then so it's like really
interesting to know i think young people
like all those movies i've been watching
reaction videos they they like all that
[ __ ] they get they they understand it
they understand it
my brother says
yeah my kids because he has a bunch yeah
um oh hang on dismiss
what is that christmas oh
it's a email from amazon
my kids mostly roll their eyes when i
try to get them to watch older movies
except for spaceballs
that one is very popular it's funny this
is my brother
yeah he has uh two older girls and two
like younger
boys yeah how old are they
um you watch them the girls are
teenagers the boys are probably
you get how old are your kids now we
gotta get them to watch horror
yeah
they're probably like um
tweens or yeah
like i think they're almost they're
getting to that age
it's been a long time about you but i'm
getting hungry again
calm down yeah
i said i watched the shining cape here
yeah and more of both my kids
that one by kubrick with the doctor
strangelove deal okay
i mean
i don't know i still like i said i'm
always kind of interested how
children that grew up without that
cultural context how do they
well i mean it's not that weird because
like i watch
silent movies and i watch like [ __ ] from
the 50s and stuff like that and i wasn't
alive back then yeah i don't understand
the cultural context but i can put
myself back in that
time period and i can still enjoy stuff
from
the silent era for example or from the
30s or 40s or 50s i still watch stuff
from back then and i can still enjoy it
so i imagine that like
people nowadays would still have that
maybe
you don't know
you don't know
uh
patriot says youngest is 16 now damn
holy [ __ ]
seriously
how long has it been since i've seen you
wait your youngest one
is 16.
[ __ ] where have i been
where have i been
hanging out in here holy crap yeah holy
crap working
i'm doing shows writing stuff doing
reviews
it's been working time's been going on
yeah
we need to like get to it like seriously
amanda's coming down in october
we need to like go do some [ __ ]
she's coming to like the disney parks i
can't afford that but
we'll meet up we'll meet up
16. holy crap
camp guy says uh cape fear been 14 years
since i yeah i think really yeah okay
i thought i watched the godfather one
cold opening with my daughter because
it's got that mortician dude whose own
daughter drank whiskey with his boy's
detour
i mean
i don't know this is like kind of some
because i watch like a lot of horror
channels and a lot of horror channels
nowadays
uh you know the people that do the
horror channels they have children who
are teenagers or in their 20s
and they will show the movies
to their kids
because they're as curious as i am yes
uh
you know how do they react to something
that happened like way before they were
born what
what's the reaction um
most of the time they seem pretty
receptive to which is interesting to me
yeah it's interesting they seem very
receptive
well i think that's kind of like um
you have to think like in modern
you know you look at something like uh
stranger things or something like that
where
they're using like 80 [ __ ] or something
like that it's just like very so it's
very relatable i think to people that
weren't born in that time period yeah
so
they can kind of like
relate to it on some level even though
they weren't born then
i don't know it's that's very kind of
interesting to me it's very interesting
to me
um camp guy said we let our kids watch
anything they wanted to
we explained a lot of the context i
think that's probably the best way to go
about things um
when i was growing up
in the 70s and 80s
my parents did not
um
forbid us from washing anything so we
just like watch whatever
but
you know if we wanted to ask them about
stuff we could
so
i think that's kind of the best way to
go about things
you get an impatient yeah you're getting
impatient yeah
you hungry yeah i'm getting hungry what
are you gonna make it late are you gonna
grocery sandwich
um
okay
you got tomato soup to go with it no no
no of course you don't no
take too long to make that
oh wait i gotta hang over my
wow
i'm sorry i gotta eat off my sister
speaking of family members
all right so
tom's getting cranky is she a blatant on
me so
we've been on for three hours so i'm
gonna have to like put him to bed
i'm gonna cook
all right so hopefully okay we'll we see
we'll see you guys on sunday and we're
gonna be talking i'm gonna spoil it yeah
on sunday we're gonna be talking about
the toby hooper movie
invaders from mars yeah yeah it was a
good movie because we just watched that
last night
yeah which i was excited about because
i haven't seen it watch invaders from
mars and we'll talk about it yeah well
it's on shutter so go watch it i mean
i'm sure it's other places but yeah we
talk about that on sunday
so
thank you guys for hanging out with us
on this friday evening
and we will see you guys on sunday have
a good weekend
we'll see you guys
sunday evening
bye